une production du studio sf bio sans
filtre le podcast on parle de ce qu'on
veut nous inviter dadis est super
content avec moi dôme plantes
si vous voulez encore plus de contenu
dirigez-vous vers notre page pétri on
voit ce qu'on fait là encore moins de
filtres ou est ce qu'après chaque pas de
casque on discute pendant 20 à 30
minutes
nicole d'hommes mois de la conversation
convient d'avoir ou est ce qu'on
reproche un petit peu nos conversations
fait que le lien pour s'abonner au
pétrole et dans la gestion du podcast
cette semaine d'hommes cette semaine on
reçoit notre ami india desjardins ont
une belle conversation autour des thèmes
de son nouvel ouvrage sont délaissés mr
big ou la glorification des amours
toxiques on a parlé un peu de comment la
fiction puis précis plus précisément les
comédies romantiques influence la
manière dont on perçoit dont on vit là
mopi comment la fiction justement at
large influence son comportement dans la
vie c'était vraiment super pares
attention nous si vers la fin du podcast
comment changer de sujet pour parler du
documentaire 6 pb 6 si vous avez prévu
sur ses six pour les regarder
c'est un documentaire qui parle de la
surpêche en fait piquer de commvault la
flore et la faune marine et india espère
engager pour la protection des baleines
et de tout ce qui vit dans la presse que
c'était super beau de la voir passionné
par ce sujet ça faisait un petit bout
même pas parlé avec une vegan véganisme
kane diack et vegan
dans sa vie faites juste avant cette
conversation là on va aller remercier
nos commanditaires qui nous permettent
de faire le podcast à chaque semaine le
podcast est présenté par police lit pour
les aime beaucoup et nous encourage son
podcast on y remercie c'est une
entreprise québécoise qui fait des
articles pour le sommet des matelas et
des oreillers tout ce qu'il y avait
autour de ce lien s'ennuie décès sur les
matelas donc si vous voulez changer de
matelots
c'était probablement trop longtemps que
vous dormez sur la même marque claudie
peut-être moins frais qui est qu'il
était jadis bat maintenant pour essayer
le match la police lippi ci-après en
date 200 nuits des 6 faisait pas
satisfait pour retourner gratuitement
yvon le donnait à l'organisme donc pas
de risque à prendre si moi j'utilise les
oreillers poney slip et je les adore yes
puis avec la saison des déménagements
qui s'en viennent
vous allez probablement en fait il ya
sûrement beaucoup d'entre vous qui vont
discuter leurs vieux matelas
tiens on voit les matelas sur le bord de
la route le pendant le déménagement
sachez que laisser votre matelas comme
cela il va être dans un site de dons pis
c'est un désastre écologique donc pas
leslie pour un guide en ligne pour vous
dire quoi faire avec votre vieux matelas
pour le recycler donc si jamais vous
pensez vous achetez à mettre le policier
vous voulez discuter votre ancien
matelot aller voir leur guide en ligne
on va mettre le lien dans la déception
on a un code promo évidemment pour vous
avec la gagne n'est pas dit cela c'est
poli sfm comme manon 25 donc pour 25 %
de rabais toutes les infos vont être
encore une fois dans le destin du
podcast le cas des valides
du 25 mai au 14 juin donc ça se passe
maintenant pendant que vous entendez ça
merci lagasnerie police lui bobo doudou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
arrête par cimzia ça lui allouer une
deuxième prise dans notre studio
maintenant l'exemple temps après à ce
qu'il veut même plus que deux habitants
contre eux reçoivent ça aurait été un
plaisir pee wee me semble que la
dernière fois le derrière moi y avait
comme une photo d ivoire cheveux trop
quoi encore le sont aussi
c'est ce qui nous suivent c'est drôle
parce que je pense qu'on a déjà
rencontré l'histoire super casse mais
les premiers pas dia ce qu'on fait c'est
ma cuisine c'est plat pour la première
fois depuis mon fils jean mallet ça
prendra quelque chose au moins pour
mettre à l'arrière tiff que je t'avais
ou à marle supprimer un quart de
chewbacca up beat que je sais pas
comment il s'appelle lenox hill il est
nouveau ici c'est notre seul élément de
décor ligne ont suivi mon au moins un
peu plus d'éléments d'accord mais
délivre sa manière comme on a reçu
patrick senécal chamakh c'est toi qui
avait fait le lien entre nous et patrick
senécal on avait mis juste germinal de
zola à l'arrière lui cédant son
engagement qui a plus lieu comme on le
voyait jamais puis il ya plein d'enfants
tués comme une caméra clip qu'on n'est
pas allé dessus on a perdu parce qu'on
ait perdu mais il fait qui est juste
comme dans deux ans les conversations
1,3 seconde convoi germinal de zola
vêtements quelqu'un rapatrient leurs
marques
l'attentisme comment comment ça a été
deux années les deux dernières années
comment s'est passé ben c'est on parle
la pandémie et c'est quelque chose
lo tan et d'arrangements soulier jetant
sur dix avaient toutes effacées
je sais pas si vous êtes comme tous les
autres si le même mois l'année passée
qu'à la pandémie est arrivé bon on
pensait tout que ça allait durer deux
semaines
même dans votre foyer d'esprit critique
et olivier non évidemment olivier lui ce
qu'on vit en ce moment c'est comme si
lui et tout m'est témoin je peux tenter
optimiste qui me disaient se jeter je me
disais qu'à qui me disait ben ça peut ça
ça peut durer un an et demi deux ans et
le cheval mais voyons mettez au début
quand on a reçu ce je pense qu'on
pensait tout que ça allait durer deux
semaines
si la presse us à continuer plus
longtemps puis on était toute la contrée
que tout ce qui s'est passé avant le
rush et même plus c'est quoi la vie
d'avant ça a été à la fois on dirait le
scud qu'une mission que ça a été à la
fois la l'année qui a passé le plus vite
mais l'année la plus longue
oui c'est la dot com puis je comprends
ce que tu veux dire c'est comme ça on
n'a pas trop la nation du temps puis
j'arrêtais pas de dire on a tout pour
l'année qu'on pensait qu'on aurait dit
je me souviens le que ea au jour de la
haye 2020 on était dans la famille
d'olivier puis on avait fait un tour de
table pour ckoi sais quoi qui ont rêvé
pendant l'année on n'avait aucune big
sam et non plus un mois plus tard il y
arrive tout ce petit bain un mois
maintenant deux mois plus tard fait que
tu es tout ce qu'on pensait vivre
pendant cette année là il ya comme fallu
qu'on veut un ajustement que je sais pas
vous mais moi au début rejet vécu un
état d'anxiété que c'est moi j'allais à
200 km h
à fond sur mes projets g j'avançais le
dit la [ __ ] dans le tapis
mais arrêtez c'est clair quant à la
[ __ ] dans le tapis le c'est un choc le
csic c'est vraiment comme si j'avais
foncé dans le pare-brise que j'ai
vraiment vécu un choc de devoir
m'arrêter qui ce choc le est en tout cas
une chance qu'ils aient eu le podcast
avec sa libido
parce qu'avec le cia ne le touquet de
vérifier la technique pour le stress
mais ça a été sous tout le monde quand
le véhicule en perte de contrôle tout ce
qui se mange et et au beaucoup de demi
projets qui ont été mis de côté qui ont
été arrêtées tout ce qui est vraiment
fallu moyens une partie du début de la
pandémie
ok priez pour moi vous irez l'ange pages
et des questions et choisit de la
peinture à numéros
alors j'ai pris congé de ma tête j'avais
deux connecteurs jallet mais des bleus
lors jamais des bleus sera exactement
j'étais là je veux qu'on me dise quoi
faire
fac bleus 56 bleus le choix c'est des
belles couleurs
c'est il fallait que ce soit justement
turquoise rose blanc ses couleurs
l'homme faisait du bien
vous avez fait que fac seule page
écouter des podcasts pendant que je
faisais mais ça a été ma seule façon de
sortir de ma tête
des fois je donne le truc aux gens parce
que on dirait que des fois quand on sait
les gens qui vivent d épuisement
professionnel ou des dépressions
soissons poker ils savent pas comment
faire pour arrêter de travailler
je le fais de la peinture à numéros
visuellement mais comme il y en a pas de
bons choix peinture à numéros le jeu si
je veux faire de l'achat local mais
coûte c'est tout des affaires de chevaux
puis de loup le dis ici au québec qu'on
trouve moche comme non je passe outre
buddy bell d'affaires fait que je ne
pouvais plus voyager fait que je faisais
des paysages d'italie
ils se perdent et voyager à travers ce
j'ai voyagé à travers ma peinture à
numéros
moi j'ai pas le talent de la peinture
qui jolie peau fac et puis là je
laissais centre est un aigle sur la
table de cuisine puis 10 olivier olivier
c'est mon job
olivier ça dérange subite soutenant
willy tchèque est là la preuve
mais c'est un bon c'est un bon truc
c'est juste d'essayer d'arrêter de faire
spin est ton cerveau ans et c'est ce qui
se passe le team au cg dernièrement j'ai
j'avais des problèmes anxieux puis de
stress négatif la façon que j'ai trouvée
c'est que je me mettais j'ai commencé à
prendre des bains beaucoup puis avec de
la musique instrumentale électro puis je
fais juste mettre mes écouteurs puis le
jeu juste penser à rien il se passe rien
du tout mais ça me fait le plus grand
bien
c'est ça a rien que nous avions exposé
c'est un luxe qui est trop d'affaires
télé réseaux sociaux les ya trop
d'affaires il ya trop d'informations
puis à un moment donné le pendant la
pandémie
c'était trop d'information de formation
c'était comme si puis il y avait été ça
a commencé rapidement aussi la colère
il ya eu lieu il ya eu une vague où tout
le monde est positive s'est paré de
jaune ça faisait ce bien plus que seuls
les gens était fâché fâché conclu les
icônes contre les mesures lancées contre
toutes sortes d'affaires puis le moi je
suis pas sensible déjà sauf de ce piège
j'étais juste plus qu'à papy c'est
surtout aussi je me sentais impuissante
je me disais est moins donne envie le ma
job l' acer à faux col existe je le
disais je mets cela ça m'a vraiment
créer de l'anxiété de servir à rien
c'est à ce moment là à ce moment ci et
bayer sur demande que pour occuper leur
esprit êtes été terrible mais c'est ce
qu'est un moment donné tu finis par te
dire mais moi je m'en acheter comme au
début le j'étais stressé parce que je me
disais qu'est les gens perdent leur job
j'ai pas envie qu'ils achètent de milly
fait que je voulais mettre mes livres
qui est accessible gratuitement du
vaccin avec mes maisons d'édition ils
ont été vraiment courir pendant
certaines parties y avait mes livres qui
étaient disponibles gratuitement
sait on dirait que samassa mort permis
de reprendre un certain contrôle sur mes
émotions puis mon sentiment
d'impuissance
parce que je me disais ah ben je sers à
quelque chose ou si je m'étais je
m'étais prononcer sur avoir d'empathie
pour les jeunes qui avaient de la peine
pour leur bal parce que les gens
diminuer beaucoup leurs émotions
ça m'a donné un sentiment aussi de me
sentir utile à quelque chose à dire et
arrêtons me drire des jeunes se disent
husky ce qu'ils vivent les jeunes en ce
moment là deux de devoir faire le deuil
comme ceux d'un rituel qui est important
pour passer à autre chose faite et c'est
dit c'est comme si on aurait appris à
que des petites choses simples
deviennent finalement des choses qui
sont qui sont importantes mais je pense
que ça nous a tout permis des prises de
conscience autre que je sais pas si vous
obtenez des prises de conscience de ce
qu'est ce qui est important dans vie
puis qu'est-ce qui est qu'est-ce qui
moins important bin moi ça m'a permis de
me réajuster on dirait par rapport à
justement ce que je vous disais de
dallas 200 km heure puis la date arrêtée
sec mais là peut-être de rouler comme de
rouler différemment puisque tu dirais ou
ski sentiment de peur du contrôle de la
situation si je reviens c'est olivier
pétré c'est une des sources
dre ce type la pandémie c'est ce c'est
quelque chose qui est tellement plus
grand que nous peut on peut rien y faire
dire la pandémie et le hâle existe pitt
et à nous attaquer dit dont on ne te
contrôle sur les actions quand vous
posez mais après ce le nombre de cas au
québec coûte ce jeudi on n'a pas de
contrôle là dessus la pandémie sa vie
réelle
face à l'ire et le type ce fax ce titre
imaginé y faire des petites actions qui
justement disait moi ce que je peux
contrôler cette section le mais aussi
accepté qui est
quand on n'a pas de contrôle qu'on
pourra pas tout contrôler ce qui se
passe à manille fois faut s'accepter qui
peut être colère peut être simulé mais
ça ça n'a pas de bon sens cette somme
est amené trois contrôle là-dessus fax
est ce qu'on peut faire c'est comme agir
sur ce qu'on peut contrôler il reste vol
il faut être capable de les services et
dans le podcast de saône elle tient à
l'aide d'une phrase que c'est maintenant
ma phrase aller dit il ya des mammouths
qu'on peut laisser passer
puis écoute maintenant je pense qu'au
moins une fois par jour le mettons
quelque chose va me déclenché à un
stress
le chef est un système c'est pour mon
mammouth ces mammouths le jeu peut
laisser passer même anecdote personnelle
mon jeune ya un mammouth dans son bureau
au caire puis il moi il m'a confié qu' à
ce même boulot depuis une dizaine
d'années parce qu'il y avait vu une
conférence de sonia lupien il y avait
trompé sur et elle les avait trompés
soutient mahmoud en figurines qui
représente que des fautes ans qui vit du
stress et regarde ce même moteur mais je
savais même pas qu'il me le confier
après qu'on ait tous les deux votre
podcast rhdp la team a confié c'était
quelque chose que j'avais possible
une phrase qui m'a marqué qu'elle a dit
c'est tout le monde a quitté sa cage
dans pandémie de s'épiler critiquer l
opt sacoche à cause de son fils le
bateau scrabble c'est qu'ici c'est pas
drôle sinon nous que mr hommes étaient
là aussi quand je vois du monde la
colère du montre les réseaux sociaux
font chinoise mais dit ouais péter
sacoche pigeât ont envie du stress qu'on
ait jamais vécu un été en ondes
d'associations que jamais vécu les gens
sont à bout des gens sont stressés pis
les gens sont pas dans leur état normal
fac on dirait que je puisse cas pas dans
les débats de pardonner les sais pas si
je me dis c'est une réaction normale aux
stress ce qui se passe tellement et moi
l'autre jour mais je me sens comme
chicaner avec moi j'aime pas je trouvais
que c'était long qui met ses bottes
en somme il m'a regardée via dit ouais
si c'est un problème de coupons et
d'alfred si vous êtes si je m'étais dit
pourquoi chu pourquoi je comme irrité de
tuchan j'ai repensé à sonia ce qui est
dit dans votre podcast puis je m'étais
dit ok la fin des bottes le sait c'est
la fête mais si je pète pas dit que je
l'avais pas fait débaucher
il faut que je te dise quelque chose le
matin le calme était yves baudelot c'est
long c'est bon je parlais je pense que
tu viennes isère de la chienne est la
france qui disait 22 à 30 jours après le
début du confinement le c'est comme le
sexe a sauté avec les bouchons ont sauté
pour beaucoup de monde
puis je parler de tout avec des amis la
fin de semaine passée puis tout le monde
si reconnu ouais tout le monde à faire
déjà ouais ça m'est arrivé dans les deux
à trois semaines trois quatre semaines
après le début du confinement il ya une
grosse chicane pour deux couacs hip hop
show était plat plus plusieurs échelles
de gravité maintenant le met tout le
monde sur connu dans quelque chose
qu'une seule
c'est fou qu'un club c'est ce papier
cela on en parle depuis tantôt le tir
est rentré ici le tournant pas rien mais
c'est un chez 2k et moi je l'écoutais
deux fois j'en ai besoin des fois j'en
ai besoin pour ma santé le jeu comme ok
le rendu à ré écouter le podcast avec
sonia lupien tim james hook et vous
appelle me prouver j'aime tout de ce
podcast leçons chez de riches qu'aux que
ça devrait être comme écouter dans les
écoles ça devrait on se fait écrire
moyen du monde qui me critiquent eux
il ya un an on parlait justement dans un
cours de psycho dans un cours sur le
stress ou même montré sa des étudiants -
ya beaucoup de personnes qui me suivent
parce que j'écrivais des livres pour les
jeunes du primaire l'apprentissage de la
lecture qui fait qu'ils aient beaucoup
de jeunes professeurs qui me suivent qui
me disent qu'ils en parlent dans leurs
courtisans façon pisser comme crime
c'est ça en dit long comme un outil
qu'est ce que cette femme la quête
extraordinaire qui fait des conférences
partout à travers la planète
ici au québec on dirait qu'on la
connaissait pas tant que ça puisque la
ccam qui nous ont fait quelque chose
avec un entrevue deux heures puis ça
devient ne pas casser le plus écouté
pour faire un pitch de films j'ai écrit
une comédie romantique dans mon pitch
j'ai écrit que sonia lupien dans votre
nom a dit qu'il faut changer notre
conception sur les films qui est n c'est
que les femmes positif ça devrait être
déclaré comme bon pour la santé mais
avait quitté le film bon pour l'esprit
marin c'est bon pour la santé mentale
j'ai mis la note enfin bon benzema petit
même les films qu athènes mais juste là
la quétainerie de ce constat et haine
c'est des fous je suis le monde prix bas
mais c'est quand même c'est juste
positif mais oui et bons sentiments
comme si les bons sentiments
c'était n'était pas racontable que
c'était que c'était considéré tout à
reléguer aquitaine qui attisait faut
changer sous peu je suis tellement
d'accord que ça fait tellement longtemps
que je dis supplie mois et pendant la
pandémie le monde somme que jamais voulu
regarder de comédie romantique le sait
sauf que tu j'ai j'en analysés pour mes
livres mais lui finalement au début il
faisait comme un peu par esprit
scientifique comme pour eux c'est comme
aller avec
lisez les rangs du team amende
oui c'est sûr que ma grille d analyse
fait que williams ou parce que lui il le
regarde avec cette analyse
ça nous donne des sujets de conversation
mais dites-moi lajus capable de regarder
des films
de même en ce moment et puis moi le
hockey la pandémie mourad eu tellement
dans un niveau d'anxiété écoute avant
d'écouter un film là je vois sur le site
donne de 2,2 de dubaï
ok ça existe deux jedi là aussi la
famille à un chien qui mord du disco
lies et demi ce nom la fête semaine
passée le mans limoges paul attachée aux
animaux le mets toi te pleure quand les
animaux morts non non non non un peu non
les animaux en général moi quand j'étais
plus jeune
puis ça ça c'est ma mère a pourrait
témoigner là les seuls films qui me
faisait pleurer c'était les faits -
est-ce que à la fin il fallait que
l'enfant se séparent dans le sens où
c'était toujours le singe fait que
c'était soit ferme et on est bon on to
be wild le film born to be wild parce
qu'il le sait comme un singe qui l'ont
goryl plus l'enfant joue avec ta faim
ils les bars la gueule d'ange ample les
120 ch plus durer ico à côté seul moi je
faire j'étais quand il est impossible
pour moi du terme et à pleurer
mais cette semaine on a regardé le il ya
un chien qui apparaît à jean vingt
minutes pas sur moi si je trouve que
chez marc jacobs pas capable de sa
classe a dit tout ces gens sont sur le
site
bon y'a une bibitte qui meurt
métis toubib qui comme méchant et y est
ok ça explique tout ce qu'on entend on
entend parler qui est un show qui marche
on le voit pas mort et mais les schémas
repos a peut-être que c'est peut-être
que ça vous touche
il ya un robot qui marquait ce afin de
terminer à temps c'est un robot qui
[Rires]
adore deux lycées touchés pandémie on a
regardé tout bébé le film à l'évier
puits - dont les analyses et un peu avec
le test de beagle petite soupe fait
c'était pour l'analyser mam et j'avais
jamais vu - terminez toi qui l'as moi
quand j'ai vu ce film le fromage et j'ai
vraiment aimé cela jetait commandes
hustache assez le 2-2 le dos et le 200
c'est la douche les deux sachets david
montgomery 2001 qui cédait 2,6 étudiants
c'est trop cher ces jeunes femmes online
que si le cas ça finit jeter comme ben
voyons toutes les suites on peut
rapporter la wii pourquoi les suites
même rapport le même à aix ou les
télécoms par rapport aux non plus si je
me pose vraiment la question de pourquoi
il ya eu 10 8 après première master chez
deux deuxièmes haimer qu est devenu le
joueur de franchise vache à lait du film
et dieu écrit le site c'est dommage je
passe d'un chai deux vaches
comment est-ce que terminator il survit
aux tests
beck d'elle quelques tubes en battant
nantes on est simple le test jak2 c'est
en fait ça vient d'aller avec dell qui
est une bd istres on dit aussi parfois
le thé le test de bec des lois là c'est
parce qu'elle a inventé avec une amie
mais bref
elle a dit que à 10 aces dans une bd à
discute avec son ami puis a dit que pour
apprécier un film il faut qu'il y ait au
moins deux personnages féminins beaucoup
à la pression un fumoir pour apprécier
comme selon son échelle selon son
échelle mais elle a parlé
personnellement je suis devenu un test
par april est par contre pour c'est pour
me battre je veux dire le test la
preciosa mais bon deux personnages
féminins
non non toute sonnerie et qui parle
d'autre chose que quand on lui donne
d'un homme
ouais mais tu peux parler d'un homme
mais autre chose que ce j'ai coûte un
podcast américain qu'il y en as lease
les lits film avec ce test le puits ce
qui est vraiment drôle c'est que
d'autres ils ont rajouté une ont rajouté
une affaire c'est qu'il faut que ce soit
pas pendant au moins deux lignes de
dialogue parce que parce que des
feuilles qui ce cri de ceux qui
s'insultent mettons le web etc seul ça
passe le test métier souvent les faits
les films passent le test parce que deux
filles deux films deux fils insultes
mais ce mois ci il ya plein de nuances
l'adapter sur game et on termine et un
le personnage à parle pas avec 10 as
parle pas avec d'autres il y est dans
tout sur les filles dans le film ce qui
est un peu plate mais je trouve quand
même que est pas objectif y as beau avec
des hommes parce que c'est une autre
affaire que j'ai découvert pendant mes
recherches souvent les femmes se battent
avec des chandeliers ou leur sacoche ou
est ce aussi si tu regardes mettons la
môme il écoute la fila dans l'eau tout y
est
le petit new tu m'as fait juste se
battre avec des chandeliers ou des
poêles à frire dans indiana jones
aussi le premier le hbh avec une part
pour l'afrique
vadasz mais avec des potes en plus c'est
que c'est un personnage dans une
direction dans le premier disons oui
marine si c'est la première fois qu'elle
rend qu'à la rencontre d'art est en
train de se claquer des shots avec wigan
album puis aller en reste debout puis
les gars tombiez comme bad ass
mais aussitôt que indiana jones arrive
j'ai découvert tellement à faire sur la
nage mais j'avais un chapitre là dessus
puis je les coupe et puis finalement
pris comme un jour j'ai peut-être le
réutiliser j'en parlais pas tout de
suite mais j'ai découvert bain des
affaires c'est sûr mais bref free mais
rien ne pourrait pas se battre avec un
fusil mais qu'en cas pognon fusil soit
qu'elles échappent où et pourquoi je me
souvienne elle est en gynéco et amateur
2 puis comme étant mes cousines étaient
le puits il
ils la voyaient le personnage de sarah
connor il faisait vraiment un outil pour
l'époque c'était comme vraiment rare
d'avoir un personnage fort comme c'est
fini cagliari your way
il y avait un jeune maton et maintenant
je fais un effort mais encore le et
l'yonne personnage assez sexuelle c'est
pourquoi à un moment donné à se ramasse
en bobettes pour autant besoin d'un
vaisseau spatial le moins sceptique
hennezel transparent c
mais oui c'est un personnage fort mais
c'est comme souvent font remarquer que
quand il ya un personnage féminin fort
mais avait avant de venir un peu comme
un fantasme masculin effectué c'est ce
qu'on appelle le le regard masculin ou
août c'est le meilleur qu'ils fait que
c'est c'est ma petite voix m'a comme moi
j'ai trippé sur wonder woman 1984 qui se
retrouve à la pandémie parce que c'est
vraiment c'était une super héroïne
vraiment dans le regard féminin puis moi
je me disais si j'avais eu cette
histoire héroïne le film a été critiqué
pour les raisons que moi je l'aimé à
l'équité critiqué par ne pas être un
vrai super héros dans le fond mais
pourquoi un super héros ce serait
absolument la version go de super héros
moi j'ai trouvé ça autre que la bataille
finale ce soit une bataille d'empathie
si je trouvais chez moi j'ai trouvé ça
génial
ça existe pas c'est le fun que patty
jenkins est qu'il a écrit pour alizée
mais ça j'ai trouvé ça vraiment autre
que calais osé ce qu'elle ait osé un
personnage qui amoureux qui inquiète
amoureuse et sexy mais pas sexualisé et
c'est ce qui ôte puis sa bataille finale
c'est une bataille dans bâtiment j'ai
trouvé ça j'ai déjà en parle j'ai des
frissons j'ai j'ai lu j'ai lu ton et
c'est en fait il ya je définis les
finisseurs puis j'ai adoré ça on en
parlera évidemment plus en plus en
profondeur tantôt mais quelque chose que
ça m'a fait c'est que hier soir que j'ai
passé la soirée à revoir dans ma tête
plein de films qui est qui habitait mon
imaginaire et de les passer à travers
justement ce test là mais aussi à
travers la vision des relations petite
toupie toutes ces choses le puits pour
réaliser que dans ce que je sentais
qu'il y avait un désir qui commençaient
à arriver deux justement mettre en place
des personnages féminins justement avec
one to one parce que one woman le
premier qui on fait avec
avec cette actrice le donjon mobile non
gaga
le premier qu'ils ont fait moi quand je
l'aï vu je me rappelle même pas ces
commentaires alors fait m'a dit chris le
legay useless le goûter le gueut dans le
fond le y est exactement le love
interest de n'importe quel film milk
mais lost highway puis j'avais trouvé ça
j'ai fait qu il est comme il est comme
un changement de paradigme le danseur
ouais
puis j'ai lu un livre qui s'appelle
justement leurs oeufs d'or et féminins
des iris breuil et à l'analyse justement
sur pied a dit que justement le gore
moment donné de se le voir bédaine dans
l'eau qui est pas sexualisé elle a le
regard puis dans son monde à elle tous
les corps les corps nus tout seul c'est
pas sexuel fac elle a le regard bien tu
as une demande petit considérées comme
un bon guide attenante atlanta assis
tout seul
et puis lui fait baroin est plus plus
que la moyenne ce qui se vante un peu
mais j'ai trouvé ça l'fun puis c'est un
bon gars c'est ce même dans le deuxième
film c'est un bongo c'est ce qui est le
fun c'est les deux les deux lions une
relation égalitaire plus souvent dans
les films de super héros mais les filles
sont un peu secondaire à part s'ils sont
elles-mêmes super héros mais s'ils sont
des civils mais tombe et ils sont
considérés comme peu son poste si bien
conçu des têtes iron man avec l'année
passée quand même quand j'étais petit le
stand filles étaient des gens très
technique et pitié et ex téléphone bi je
pense pas que tu aies par avait juste
pour un rôle aussi important métier en
même temps l'importance époque que
toutes les firmes répondre à tous les
critères du sommet au moins qu'avec la
diversité puis donne à voir un one woman
avec ses laisser les femmes qui sont
premier plan qui peut-être que les
gosses on peut au premier plan ci est
exactement pareil mais au moins ce
cheminot ici cemac oreilles peas mais
c'est ça mais c'est que je pense car il
connaît bien comme de plus en plus le
theater when i was not for black widow
kiki qui s'en vient et a eu beau doivent
près avec les dons de super héros qui a
un marteau a dit lulu rose bleu comme
l'appelait la sortie jack straw ou
est-ce que ces centres et là tu fais je
me dis oh moi aussi mais ton t ça m'a
fait le même effet qu'un que j'ai écouté
black panther le titre qui bondit pour
la première fois je regarde un film qui
met en scène des noirs mais mais d'un
point de vue nous ôtons en cinq sets
anticon six points points écrit par des
blâmes et met en scène des noirs et
d'autre des films les springfield et
film de spike lee des familles à la
prière il y en a déjà mais montrer tes
devoirs de leurs gros films mainstream
de super héros mais en changeant les
codes les modèles parce que c'est super
retard d'avoir toutes sortes de
représentations puis autant féminines
que autant de personnes physiques de
personnes handicapées tj un article
cette semaine si les gens veulent se
reconnaître dans les histoires qui dit
moi j'ai l'impression est peut-être que
c'est utopique mais j'ai l'impression
que la fiction peut faire partie de la
solution
j'ai l'impression que si on raconte
toujours les histoires de la même façon
basé sur les mêmes codes qui viennent de
yole super longtemps de toute façon mais
j'ai l'impression que en ce moment on
contribue au modèle social problématique
puis je trouve que c'est important de
mettre toutes sortes d'histoires en
scène qui qui raconte des histoires
différentes mais aussi positive sur
toutes sortes de groupes marginalisés de
la société qui je pense que plus on va
faire ce plus on va mettre des dunes
faire germer des nouvelles dépit d'une
nouvelle perception ccim et ont un
personnage handicapés y est tout le
temps victime ben finalement on voit
victimiser tout à ces gens là puis je
pense même que ça peut ne pas aider la
perception de soi même dit donc si moi
j'étais une femme puis que dans les
fictions et ben les femmes sont toujours
inférieurs sont toujours savent pas se
battre que leur seule kate c'est l'amour
mais peut-être que ça va influencer la
perception de moi même
c'est bon j'ai fait des recherches là tu
pue ça donne pas exactement cette
réponse le t2 lu mon livre les études
loti c'est vraiment partagé à gelos eu
des notes quand même beaucoup d'exemples
où parce que moi c'est l'aspect ton
livre qui m'a le plus frappé est en moi
même quelqu'un qui
qui a fait de la fiction qui du moins
vise à en faire ou un continent fort
l'importance de la fiction et son reflet
dans la société petit des notes quand
même beaucoup d'exemples way de trucs
fictionnel qui ont eu un impact réel
dans la société
puis je vous dire même si les réponses
sont pas même si on est d'attribuer
justement les tueries à call of duty
maintenant c'est pas vraiment nécessaire
si on est capable de quand même retracé
certaines certaines directions team et
ont des tremplins le tu peux peut-être
oui mais pour les gens qui ont dit a
fallu bon dans les exemples il y en a un
qui m'a vraiment marqué jazz
oui oui oui jazz a eu un impact majeur
dans la société parce que hein
tout d'abord il y augmenter la peur des
requins moi le moi le premier quand j'ai
écouté jazz sa mort jack quand j'étais
déjà ça m'a pris un bon une semaine
parce que moi je faisais de la natation
déjà trois fois par semaine à ce moment
là c'est pis je vais acheter aux siens à
l'abri quand la piscine c'est fleming
non non pas le symbole c'est le manque
de compétition s'appelait veste et une
piscine du cégep le thb 0 mais ça m'a
pris un bon même à y aller trois fois à
voir la chienne un vrai chien de la
cause de jazz ainsi imaginé des ricains
d'amap signer les parents quand j'étais
jeune j'écoutais cfm loti ci s'appuie ça
le fait qu'il ait recruté chasser le ben
oui le la peur des requins augmente et
la chasse aux requins mais ce qui est
positif a précisé que la chasse de la
chasse aux requins qui était quand
incontrôlable parce que les gens avaient
peur les gens les détester les requins
donc les chasser ça a fait que ça
augmente et les études à leur sujet pour
informer la population de caisse qui
créent les attaques donc y maintenant il
ya plus de rues de réglementation pour
sauver les requins par
qu' il ya eu tout ça alors on s'entend
que du chemin à parcourir à vélo est
exactement mais c'est quand même un
impact qu'on peut mesurer la paire qui
est parti de ce film là que crée la
chasse puis après ce que obligé des
études à ce niveau le pilote à faire
dans ce que tu dis c'est par rapport à
la violence bon ce le témoin à un moment
donné je me suis trop je me suis
retrouvé dans un espèce de vortex des
tissus c'est mais ton temps et puis
chercher tous tendent à faire le
chercher sur les comédies romantiques à
manier chercher je mettais souvenu que
thil la solitudine reason why
alors bon j'avais je mettais souvenu que
c'est ce qu'elle a là je ne fais que ce
soit afin pourquoi ou fébus avait trouvé
que ça que ça avait augmenté les
suicides
jean claude job qui fait les ch'tis le
wifaq sauter ça ça prouve que ça a un
impact le finalement chercher mythique
recherche pew si je dois avouer que
c'est mon job qui m'affole mais quand
recherche quelque chose il faut toujours
que tu cherches la contracter pour voir
si comme est ce que il ya quelque chose
qui dit non tant que joueur à google qui
vous votre confirmé que cette recherche
ces sites cherchait est ce qu'elle fait
d'avoir des cheveux longs elle me rend
plus susceptibles de faire des bons
gâteaux probablement une équipe je te
chercher ce qu'il te fume fait part des
cheveux puis la société oui c'est vrai
que finalement j'ai cherché l'étude
contraire pileux ça disait que non
savait pas augmenter les suicides qui le
soja vous le des fois que j'avais de la
misère à moi-même comprendre les
conclusions là des fois j'allais voir
olivier plus je disais et peux tu
m'expliquer sait quelles études qui est
la meilleure piste et c'est quoi la
méthodologie de ce petit défaut vraiment
y est comme le la l'étude finalement de
sur tontine wizo noailles qui était la
meilleure c'est celle qui disait que non
savait pas vraiment augmenter les cotes
suicide l'homme abandonné le jeu tu es
comme un maillon il ya des études qui me
disent que oui pour les comédies
romantiques que ça influence et en a
d'autres qui disent que non
le lait jeté pagny le jeter comme
j'avais une centaine d'études de
sur toutes sortes de sujets que je
trouvais super intéressante puis je
savais plus quoi faire plus je vais
aller cogner dans le bureau de levier
judicieux quand tu dis le qu'il faut que
j'écrive consensus le savent eux qui
nous est compté pour lui le piano pas de
consensus je comprends pas que les mots
disent il faut que tu regardes dans les
grandes associations puis tout sauf
acquis montrer où chercher plus que j'ai
trouvée par rapport à ce que tu disais
c'est l'association américaine de
psychologie qui est que le consensus en
fait lorsque ce que ça réflète c'est que
les études disent des choses contraires
déjà des chercheurs suisses d'impôts
déjà je me disais oh ben finalement
j'avais compris ce jeu peut se payer 10
dans leurs conclusions ils disent que si
tu est exposé à un acte violent
ça t'inspire pas nécessairement à
commettre un acte violent s'était pas
prédisposé à deux pas de prédisposition
à la violence malgré tout si tu est
exposé à de la violence
continuellement sa pourrais te
désensibiliser à la violence kg moi je
moi je me suis questionnée c'est que si
dans certaines histoires des histoires
d'amour ou n'importe quelle histoire
certaines formes de violence envers les
femmes est banalisée ben comment on peut
faire pour s'en protéger
parce que c'est banaliser donc méconnu
donc normalisé on devient de
sensibiliser et on devient
désensibiliser le fax et là oh moi je me
dis ben ya sûrement quelque chose a
changé dans la façon de raconter des
histoires dans la façon de raconter des
histoires d'un mot pour et pour arrêter
conçoit des sensibiliser à ce et c'est
là où je me dis glorifier des histoires
d'amour toxiques ou des histoires qui
peuvent être finalement la violence
conjugale mais qu'on sait même pas que
c'est de la violence conjugale est bien
celle où je me dis ben il ya quelque
chose
le si on est des gens civilisés
à quelque chose qu'on sait même pas si
quoi que s'est normalisée que c'est
banaliser il ya quelque chose à faire
selon moi deux jours par rapport à son
programme anti sur la question des skull
lors nous influence je pense que si ça
semble excessivement difficile de tracer
une taie un lien direct entre quand un
événement là d'un film puis le ca sera
produit dans la vraie vie
mais si je prends mes ton juste mon
parcours personnel moi mettons les
oeuvres de fiction les livres que j'ai
lus les films que j'ai vus ados jeunes
adultes
samassa à former la personne que je suis
aujourd'hui ne cessa moins influencé les
valeurs des véhicules et traversent ou
seppi tristesse tout à bagages les cta
cumul surtout dans ces années là où est
ce que comme des romans de france des
années formatrices sa flore j'ai aucun
aucun doute que lors que ce soit le
cinéma où que ce soit d'autres formes
d'art influence la façon dont on pense
le monde qui ont réfléchi puis on est
passé ce jour vraiment aucun doute là
dessus
puis après ce jeu c'est plus écolo
points mais la question des glorifie
c'est là que je me pose la question
parce que tu y mets ton il ya plein de
films ou est-ce que jodie dessein
d'amour mise en scène ou sk regardant ce
pour moi c'est clair qu'est ce que je
vois c'est pau cpo c'est pas bien
et puis je me dis je crois pas que ça
soit l'intention de l'auteur de nous
faire accroire que ce seuil ce site un
bon modèle mettons tpiy moi je partais
moi j'ai jamais été vraiment un fan des
comédies dramatiques jamais été vraiment
très par se propage peu le public cible
non plus le type mais j'ai l'impression
parce que c'était une partie boisée
c'est impossible parce sa vie c'est mais
c'était peut-être que beaucoup de gens
qui voient ce qu'ils croient qu'ils se
disent ses seules vraies d'amour andré
coup j'ai jamais cru ne peut que mais je
comprends ce que tu peux dire ça rejoint
un article philosophique que j'ai vu
c'est à dire que porto l'intention de
l'auteur l'impact sacré et puis comment
toi tu l'interprète de tout soupçon on
oublie tout le temps comme notre propre
interprétation
thil probablement que toile tu te
reconnais maintenant peut-être dans le
goutte diem moi je suis pas comme togo
le monter toi t'as plein de personnages
masculins qui te ressemblent et aux
indiana jones tôt disparue roots et
toutes sortes de personnages soit pour
un seul homme sans casser rempli la
moitié comme en tant que fille j'aime
beaucoup de personnages féminins pour
seulement qui me ressemble enfin quand
je m'identifie à un personnage puis que
je laime tout surpris que le personnage
bien été finalement suisse sa qualité
est amoureuse avec 1go
c'est là où je me demande c'est est ce
que ça peut avoir comme une influence
sur moi mais mes héroïnes finalement
cédé 0 in amoureuse que lorqu'elle
toujours à trouver un homme finalement
exact c'est quand même des fois tu sais
que tu regarde juste maintenant catwoman
dans batman multi advient quand même
l'intérêt romantique un peu dedans c'est
un peu même port accusant avoir sa
propre récit il ya peut-être soudan toi
ta capacité parce que tout est large
panoplie de personnages à qui te
ressemble et qui moi c'est ce que je
demande dans mon livre si c'est peut-on
faire une vaste panoplie pour les femmes
puisque 6 à 9 si une relation amoureuse
qui est démontrée peut avoir des
conflits parce que c'est c'est dans la
façon de raconter les histoires il ya
des conflits
mais est ce que ces conflits le peuvent
être pas au détriment de la femme qui se
fait souvent inférioriser ou qui vit
souvent très des abus psychologiques ou
même sexuelle ti dans le rang tout les
films que j'ai regardé je me rendais
compte qu'il y avait souvent des
relations sexuelles banalisée l'écouté
james bond en fin de semaine à monsieur
lapin violent à chaque fois qu'ils
couchent avec oui à toutes les fois et
pas une fois parce que johnson
une relation sexuelle consentante car
pour une fois c'est lui avec monica
bellucci le mont a mis à me raconter
d'autres joueurs qui à l'écouter avec
ses fils à l'opposé sur pause le dit ban
les garçons je veux juste vous dire que
dans la vie si un homme tue le mari
d'une femme patois bien ça se peut
qu'après la femme allait pas envie de
faire l'amour avec senna qu'elle a fait
à prend sa douche dans son appart seuls
chez eux le thc pas james bond dans la
partie
le lui ce liquide dans la partie va la
rejoindre dans deux pièces avec 1 3 face
aux gabarits dans la douche c'est comme
sa potence chapeautant selon le mais
c'est l'autre jour là je lisais un
article qui sur des des jeunes hommes
hockey qui ça parlait de la pornographie
à quai le jeune homme est rayé mais il
est maintenant dans une liste de sex
offenders hockey aux états unis qui lui
disait qu' il y avait une correspondance
avec une fille sur les réseaux sociaux
lui avais je pense 19 kg elle avait dit
cette facture 19,7 sur touvre
pis le bain lui ça son éducation
sexuelle lui venait de la pornographie
qui à un moment donné il y a fait une
offre sexuelle qui était complètement
horrible je peux même pas la répéter
tignes puis legault il dit la fille a eu
tellement eu peur qu'elle en a parlé à
ses parents puis finalement et ils ont
appelé la police pleut il s'est fait
arrêter dans l'est dans la liste des six
offenders parce que la fille était
mineure qui est lui ben y'a pas proposé
d'aller se donner un french hausse n'est
pas rennes on s'était vraiment genre je
vais te pencher par an
j'étais joie très bon je peux t'imaginer
qui lui dit moi je pensais que c'était
ce que les filles voulaient et puis je
le crois moins je le crois parce que lui
la sexualité et le a pris comme ceux qui
a personne qui a dit que les filles
aiment et ceux la douceur de 6 à 17 ans
c'est probablement qu'est ce qu'elle
veut si c'est aussi un peu de romance
pic était elle n'a pas envie de se faire
rentrer dans le mur on écoute et on
était ensemble mais l'empiré contre
attaque dernièrement le tri puis en solo
pendant l'empiré contre attaque au
complet il se fait dire non oui mais il
y a ainsi insisté indice fait dire non
il se dire non il faut dire non par la
princesse léa puis le nom devient oui
éventuellement mais c'est toujours comme
ça qu'ils se contentent on tait le nom
ces noms là c'est pourquoi pourquoi pour
une seule hausse à l'époque puisque j'en
parle dans mon livre est tué dans sex
and the city qui mon fil conducteur dans
le fond pour ma réflexion
mais c'est à la fin elle lui dit non
elle lui répète non même si le lion
devient oui et puis le nom devient rien
oui parce que et trouvent la bonne
twister la bonne façon d'aller la
chercher
ce j'ai appelé sur le phénomène y eut
admis qu est le gâteau rien besoin de
faire tout petit peu traitée comme une
marque tout au long qui a faim de juste
besoin de faire ça lupino pis c'est
yoann me hatlo c'est à juste besoin de
revenus c'est les attentes sont si
basses que finalement c'est finalement
tout juste besoin de revenir puis que ça
compte
et puis moi je me questionne puis je
réfléchis là-dessus pythie quand j'ai
écrit mon livre
mon but c'était vraiment pas de
stigmatiser la culture populaire outil
les comédies romantiques parce que moi
une fan de comédies romantiques puis
j'adore ce petit déjà déjà qu'un qu'on
aime ce pays
fait traiter de quétaine justement
comment disait au début mais fleur bleue
où tout se août c'était un peu le vrai
cinéma parce que tu aime les comédies
romantiques mais moi j'adore / je veux
toujours dire que j'aime ce pays j'aime
solaire voire même si des fois j'ai dit
à mon chum pas sur pause j'ai besoin de
prendre une respiration parce que je
trouve que la fille à ce mobile est
prêté puis tout
puis je pense qu'en ce moment si on
prend une certaine distance avec les
fictions qu'on apprend à détecter ces
choses le sait ça nous empêche pas de
les émissions le mot j'arrêterai jamais
d'aimer c'est que sundin diana jones et
toutes les choses dont south stream même
si on veut on voit que et mano solo oui
mais juste d'être capable de prendre
cette distance lors de remarques et ce
sont des petites choses qu'on remarquait
pas avant ça pue ça peut juste aider
selon moi c'est drôle parce que dans mes
études le que je vous dise il est sans
doute il y avait une étude qui étaient
tous les films de voyons comme un qui
s'appelle cet acteur qui joue en solo le
tout les films d'harrison ford sont
problématiques
mais quand j'en ai regardé chose pour le
fun qui te regardent euros dans toutes
ces femmes c'est un gros mot non cash de
jeu y arrive à côté des femmes le pied
comme si ce problème vraiment plus comme
qu'elles ont un cliché une caricature de
monnaie dans un bar puis il ils ces
lignes de cruz le et que dans working
girl
ça fait mal je pense que c'était seventy
seven nights quelque chose de même aux
mondieux lui aussi quasiment écoute ça
barde les drones le même besoin sa scène
de sexualité avec la whey avec la la la
je les appelle les robots le rsa pas de
bon sens il fait juste le grand jeu dans
le mur biya dit rien le droit d'en
parler c'est un robot qui c'est comme si
les robots tu sais que métisse mais j'ai
l'impression quand même que c'est grâce
à béton tétons et seppi gisèle
l'ensemble des réflexions qu'on nous dit
critique qu'on fait j'étais quasiment
tout le temps quand je regarde une
fiction qui a été fait
bree années 2000 mettant quelque chose
qui est tout le temps ça se dit souvent
la force d'utiliser sa pourrais pas et
fait aujourd'hui mais pas parce qu'il
s'est construit physiquement empêché le
fameux jusque collectivement on a
réfléchi puis on s'est rendu compte que
justice a pas de bon sens pour le
représenter mais j'imagine que ça arrive
encore tu me dis que ça arrive encore la
pression quand même que dans les
fictions qui sont maintenant d'un
dragueur comporte pas justement tu es le
team tonga dans le costaud awa tendresse
je regarde à deux niveaux le mot niveau
tiga kill kill lès mello niveau qui dit
aux médias sociaux se hisse à peu de bon
sens apte et des capable aussi de se
dire d'un côté un autre époque autres
moeurs pia ce moment à lille c'était
vraiment pas avancer comme aujourd'hui
puis à samatan dans son contexte ce bac
divertissement mais aussi des cavales
regarder dakhla d'aujourd'hui puissent
voir qu'est-ce qui fonctionne pendant je
suis 100% d'accord avec toi puis le
contexte est vraiment important petit
dans mon livre je vais beaucoup de
contexte non seulement le contexte
historique contexte de la série bien
aussi oui je trouve que de raison que ça
s'améliore puis on voit que vraiment des
choses qui changent mais joe juste de
donner l'exemple de l'ohvn monsters que
j'ai regardé en médecine qui est un film
de thé dans le même sens sur 2021 ok
ceux qui veulent regarder le film avance
je commençais qui est un gars qui est
orgueilleuse sensible c'est un gars qui
dessine c'est un groupe le sartre situ
ce donc tu es comme tout art go et 6 go
on connaît le tc bon qu'il a quand les
cas il ya un monstre qui arrivent tous
et post apocalyptique le lait uht
quelque chose qui s'est passé qui aura
dû juste les bibliothèques des marrons
sais pas pourquoi mais bref
car les goûts vont se bat lui il reste
avec les filles cuisine c'est tout
soupçon s'est montré comme 15 même
exploit là bas et non pas un exploit
s'est montré comme il est plus fait ok
avec déjà on est en 2021 le temps même
si puis le fumier le fun à regarder le
vendredi soir le bon le lui iem une
fille ok mais ils ont été séparés dans
la dans l'apocalypse ho kim phat là il
décide de passer par dessus ses peurs
qui va aller à la surface parce qu'ils
sont obligés de vivre dans des bunkers
pour aller retrouver cette fille là
finalement coming of age il se découvre
du courage
puis le yariv à la fille qu'il a fait à
exécuter pleut ça fait sept ans que se
sont pas vues a dit et je suis contente
que tu as effectué pour moi pas tout
mais on en mange pas d'amour avec toi
fait le job et je comprends plus je me
disais cool c'est saint lô finalement et
y arrive de quoi puis lui sauvent toute
la colonie de la fille est loupé d'un
coup la fille a commencé à le regarder
comme si un cornet de crème glacée ils
allèrent garde le petit genre de jeu de
comédienne nautique quels sont vos armes
bailly ce plat devient comme un peu gêné
alors que tu risques d'une fille qui se
bouffent tout ce pilot legault il dit
bambins c'est sobre un jour tourner dans
ma collègue dans ma colonies puis à fait
ok by pileux il s'en va et revient ya
french bon il n'y a pas demandé el ayadi
jeu pas intéressés ma nana mais lui lie
à penser que parce qu'il ya été le rôles
duquel lloris à ce bail finalement il
peut la friendship puis dans les codes
du film c'est accepter
ce qui lui est devenu comme le héros ces
dix mois sa sortie le saviez northeast
ramos si je me dis que tu as étaples et
montreuil était comme s'il faisait
l'avocat du diable dit oui mais ça
arrêter quoi l'histoire de ce togolais
il fait des dessins et pendant tout le
film projeté le web images ici mettons
ces dessins ils étaient partis ne gagne
ces dessins
eide a documenté avec matin que ça
devient comme grâce à ses dessins
c'est sa documentation qui il peut son
baby ça peut être un groupe où même
exactement la même chose mais que la
fille aux prunes réaction comme ça qu'un
qui sauve le monde disparaît merci je
peux plus intéressant exact ça peut
revenir
tout se passe comme ça mais genre métier
quand même tu viens de sauver c'est
super cool intrigue c'est que tu as
trouvé le truc maltais projet de la vie
de force mais j'ai l'impression que dans
les codes du genre le spécifiquement
c'est vraiment et des espèces de 2,2 de
grosse démonstration d'amour au vu de
toupie de ty justement ne pas lâcher
d'insister je manquais personnes disent
oui pina 98 fois ci c'est vu comme le
lait le comble du romantisme cédant de
notre boucle eta ibon pouilles ils vont
pas d'en faire un tour de grande roue
qui s'accroche à un groupe idi je me
laisse tomber au début
vient d'être avec moi avec mon genre des
menaces de suicide le thé pour poker
c'est au début c'est la première fois
qu'ils les autres si je rencontre dans
une faille folie et à quoi les temps
dead avec quelqu'un d'autre lui une
demande des états dits n'ont fait que
les graines de montagne au temps de la
grande roue plus six semaines même
prédit bien des d'amour je me laisse
tomber la dit non à la loge un brin dial
viande et haguenau je laisse tomber plat
fini par dire oui mais tu sais c'était
malade manipulation mais maintenant ce
que je me posais je me suis posé cette
question
après avoir lu de ton essai par rapport
à cela parce que dans ce film lost lui
lui il s'est un peu lui qui reste le
teint est en attente des ltte
cl tu fais son back and forth qui joue
avec ces sentiments qui fait un peu le
yoyo avec lui qui sont collés sur un pic
à la fin finalement bien avec traitement
des demandes et non mais j'y
réfléchissais maintenant par rapport à
la vision que que tous décrivent l art
ont déçu par rapport aux faibles en
particulier mais je me rappelle pas si
mais c'est ça aussi c'est flou mais ça
ne m'est revenu que je médite si c'est
complètement la mannequin puis on
regarde si on se dira que c'est cute
métier de façon dans la vraie vie c'est
la chose la plus horrible je vais
raconter ça jamais été racontée sur le
parc à ce qu'il ya pleinement je sais
qui a pleinement dans le land art qui
coûte l'essentiel est fait qu ils vont
sûrement sûr qu'elle ait des troubles du
monde à la fête qui sont inclus dans le
store le qui vont l'écouter c'est une
histoire les plus jeunes je pense je
seulement lui je pense qu'ils jugent
inique
c'est tellement gênant c'est vraiment
une honte en stationnaire 3 qui jettent
at 14 entre autres qui même s'inquiéter
s'inquiètent eux c'est sympa de banquier
chaque été il ya nos amis qui une maison
sur un genre de domaine à shannon en
banlieue de québec le type qui est en
partie de la saint jean du puy le
remonter de l'école secondaire qu'elle
souhaite inviter gros party le quai
quasiment comme dans les films d'ados
justement c'est là que l'on voit la boj
avait eu une fille sont venus une finale
tendue qui elle était plus ou moins
intéressés mais possiblement peut-être
grâce aux dés à cause d'erreurs plus
grosse des films qui étaient des
histoires qu'on sait raconter qui est
instit persévère
ici tu n'as la nappe fait des grandes
déclarations d'amour cette personne ne
s'intéresse à toi ce qu'il faut ben je
me suis dit le jeu faire quelque chose
puis à manille bon la soirée avance
pilote ici lysanne aussi qu'on commence
à consommer des dab ya tous ces bons le
savez peut-être bu une coupe de bière
qui sur le alors c'est tellement gênant
ce domaine il ya un lac
il ya comme un messie un petit lac le
test fait peut-être qu'à pieds de
profond depuis ces genres un lac
artificiel très porteur meeting
d'automne transparaître de natation
facture on sait très bien hors jeu c'est
vraiment dangereux d'aller dans l'eau en
ayant consommé métiers restent jeunes
ont très bien géré mais tant que tu
puisses te rends pas compte de ce pôle
des deux siècles le jeu mais déjà la
queue juge même énergie plus tout le
monde se met à fric et fruits car le cas
il va se noyer a consommé là non plus
jeunes on écrit un mois plv
gardiennage et berlin benchikha le
jardin plus je vois que tout le monde
est sur la pente est d'arrêter tout le
monde et leur demande de changer la
rifle et témoigne ce bar de loupe capote
le chiffonnier comme un grand cercle
rouge comme dans l'autre c'est comme
qu'est-ce qui se passe pis le bhv qui
met fort de loon pilot chiffres non je
sors pas de laumac à 10 km ces
territoires mais c'est la pire chose
c'est juste la pire des cas je fais
alors voulu disparaître dans le soleil
dit pierre surtout pas dit quand même
fallu parce que ça aurait été dit plus
haut c'est comme-ci comme-ça tenir
acceptable espèce de chantage pour avoir
ce que tu lis cela possible je voyais ça
comme un grand
et voici sa com
un grain
c'est juste la petite sortie finalement
ouais je fatigue et moi c'est moi qui te
j'avais bien si justement c'est un
modèle qu'on apprend c'est un modèle
social et à prix qui est dans nos têtes
seppi ces locaux que je pense qu'il faut
qu'on se questionne là dessus en même
temps j'aimerais se dire un bémol ça
c'était vraiment intense puis le goût
qui se plaignent après la grande roue ce
soit vraiment une pensée mais dans ma
vie personnelle t comme c'est moi quand
j'ai rencontré mon job
gt gt pas prête une relation amoureuse
qui lui il a été patient
ouais c'est pas il n'ya pas insisté ou
rien yo comme accepter d'être mon ami
pin l'amour l'amour c'est créer
c'est dans une relation où on était les
deux intéressés mais au moins je n'étais
pas prête donc si mais moi je disais que
je n'ai pas pris acte et il faut faire
des bémols aussi dans c'est pas vrai que
dans ce sens que je veux pas dire qu'un
on veut dire oui moi je démontrais que
j'étais intéressé mais je n'étais pas
prête dans mon coeur puisque ça existe
ou cité phocéenne ya des nuances dans
tout se mettant comment qu'on fait la
différence quand je te mange pas prise
je prends mon temps où je peux son âme
et on sait pas ce que tu as ton bâton et
cette critique quand même mr big daddy
ce temps peuvent vouloir s'impliquer
c'est que c'est si vous coincez où ça
devient malsain au carré mais mister big
il dénigre toujours cas utile à dénigrer
s'il dit qu'il travaille sur un article
qui comme une chronique here is one de
ces sujets a man spleen c'est beaucoup
du genre
ben voyons c'est juste à côté à l'as
pose une question qui comme ben voyons
c'est juste à cause de tout et lui c'est
tout c'est lui qui des fois il vaut là
il voit la gare cela était factuellement
m'en donnez leur un exemple c'est que
moi c'est mon exemple préférer un moment
donné à l'un
dans une soirée qui peut pas travailler
puis le est la voie à la soirée puis à
lewiston qui a par là une autre gosse
pour la crosse et haï par pitié ne dit
cependant avec ce goulot finalement mr
biya arrive puis le ja voit en train de
parler l'autre gauche qui est comme
hôtes et leur petit occupée
bye bye petit loïs en aveux et puis le
elle a suivi a fait ben voyons qu est ce
que tu souhaites tu avais dit que je
pouvais pas venir ici bas le chou venu
puis j'ai passé tout le temps que
j'avais précieux à chercher fait que
baye
ça va être ça va être ça c'est de la
violence voter cdu gaslight c'est à dire
qu'elle est assez fait dire non qui
pourrait pas aller à la soirée elle est
allée pareil parce que c'est une fille
indépendante parce qu'elle veut pas tant
d'après lui à la v10 bonne à part un ou
2 go à la le droit à sort pas avec
mister b ils n'ont pas de d2 rien qu ils
sortent pas ensemble break
bref pilot finalement ya trop il est pas
content de la trouver en train de parler
un autre gueule puis le il fait comme
bombay finalement tiges suis venu à tige
tellement important je suis venu mais tu
est entrain de thé comme j'ai passé mon
précieux temps de chercher parce que
t'es pas trouvé à petit et pas trouvable
les facs et sapho ça n'est pas juste là
l'indisponibilité mais ça devient comme
justin espèce de contrôle il ya
quelqu'un dit à quelqu'un goethe
intéressé par toi mais mon coeur
financier n'est pas riche pas tout à
fait l'homme et mais que tu est
disponible pour la personne que tu as
envie de passer du temps avec elle que
tu sais que c'est que ça dure ça super
talent ça serait dans la discussion dans
la conversation en fait c'est juste des
pouvoirs dans le bain c'est sûr dans la
conscience à dire exactement précisément
donné ou wipi que une des deux personnes
l'ati la personne maintenant qui est pas
disponible c'est comme moi maintenant
dans les débuts avec mon job c'était pas
juste moi qui décide et ont décidé les
deux des moments où on a l'espoir
facture lui si ma clé ben moi je dis oui
pour pour passer du temps avec lui parce
que j'aime et se passer du temps avec
lui les petits la preuve que tu étais
juste pour
dans mon coeur c'est que aujourd'hui on
est ensemble on est mariés puis tout va
bien mais j'avais juste besoin de temps
pour mes émotions parce que j'avais vécu
des choses difficiles
par contre là où ça devient plus
problématique c'est quand une personne
te dit tu sais moi ça m'est arrivé des
gens qui disent je suis pas prêt et tu
ta terre mais que quand toi tu essayes
de passer du temps avec lui lui dit non
facture devient comme un peu son
divertissement lui gagné disponibles ben
là finalement t il eu et appelle tout ce
ce c'est la partie se servir des gens
c'est moi qui tu vois j'ai déjà eu une
relation avec un goût qu on avait une
relation de ce qui était pas on sortait
pense en mon jeu voyait quand ça nous
tentait tout seul puis à un moment donné
lui même avoué qu'il y avait des
sentiments pour moi j'en avais pas mais
ce qui aurait été de la manipulation
c'est dire ah merde je perds c'est comme
ceux de bon temps là avec cette personne
le fait que je veuille dire oh mais je
vais peut-être au début les sentiments
mais le tout est associé de la
manipulation
j'aurais pu manipuler pour le garder
mais moi ayant souffert de manipulation
j'ai dit mais je comprends qu'il faut
qu'on arrête de se voir parce que moi je
veux pas utiliser du moment que la
personne te dis j'ai des sentiments mais
tu peux pas tu peux pas utiliser cette
personne n'a que des sentiments parce
que tu sais que la personne à vos désirs
et plus fac site what's up il faut être
fou et honnête envers soi même si tout
ceci le temps développera pas de
sentiments le laisse la personne libre
ses seules ces seules la chose à faire
parce que sinon ça crée un déséquilibre
c'est ce qui crée un climat malsain
puis c'est ce qui fait qu'il ya un cycle
qui commence puis des fois
étant donné que c'est peu connu on peut
autant de victimes que bourreau sans
savoir que c'est ce qui est du style
pitt et ne pas connaître ces choses ça
fait des fois on peut avoir ces
comportements la envers les autres sans
même les reconnaître sans même on à être
coupable parce que comment tu veux être
pas de quelque chose que tu sais pas
puisque pour ce que c'est important
l'information à ce sujet est important
qu'on s'informe parce que c'est comme ça
qu'on peut
essayer de corriger nos propres
comportements puis justement je pense
que la fiction c'est un bon exercice de
l'oci j'ai déjà été comme ça puisque
pour super tu peux essayer d'être j -pd
ce biais les besoins des sarments passer
une fois par parce qu'on dit souvent vu
une fois après tout reconnaît les signes
se fait pas avoir une deuxième fois le
10 mai mettez pas si simple que ce point
que ce oui mais aussi c'est peut-être
que si on était mieux informer puis si
on avait des mères modèle on n'avait pas
besoin de passer par le pur comme savoir
c'est quoi exactement pitié je pense que
plus on va le savoir plus on va être
capable de s'en protéger plus on va être
capable de reconnaître nous même temps
nos propres comportements problématiques
t on à le droit d'être honnête envers
nous-mêmes de dix mois le g c'est comme
moi j'ai beaucoup appris sur la
communication non violente
c'est qu'ils moitié j'ai découvert au
québec dès fois parce que je tenais
secure des fois ça m'arrivait par les
plus secs à des gens avec qui je
travaillais avec parce que j'étais
tellement inférioriser dans ma vie que
moi je me disais bien pour avoir de la
crédibilité il faut que j'essaie de
m'affirmer plus mais je le faisais pas
nécessairement de la bonne façon
vacances et après ça mais quand apprend
des techniques justement de mieux pour
mieux communiquer de communiquer de
façon non violente
ttt opinion péter désir pour tous eu
finalement que ça se passe vraiment
mieux puis je pense que sur les réseaux
sociaux c'est un peu ce en ce moment des
fois il ya des gens là qui veulent
communiquer leurs désaccords mais savent
pas comment piloter quand tu es gentil
avec eux si maintenant un son spa viol
impliquant leur répond gentiment ils
vont être gérés fac des fois je pense
que c'est quelque chose qu'on devrait
apprendre dans la société la
communication non-violente essayé
d'exprimer des désaccords mais de façon
respectueuse parce que ça se peut des
désaccords
on n'est pas obligé de tout le monde est
d'accord mais si on exprime de façon
respectueuse de façon à pas de dénigrer
l'autre de façon et des jeux
ça aide énormément la discussion puis
toutes les discussions ça amène toujours
une évolution
ouais il 14 que m'est venue en lisant
ton nez c'est qui c'est une question qui
me qui m'habite quand même par rapport à
la notion de de l'amour puis dans les
comédies romantiques l'amour et comme la
valeur ultime puis on dirait que c'est
comme sert présenté souvent comme un
sentiment qui unique puis qui va
t'arriver une fois qu'il faut arriver
avec une personne puis que tu veux
passer à travers tout le cauchemar du
monde entier pour cette émotion lotis
alors que de mon expérience de veepee de
conversations en conversation avec des
gens c'est l'amour ça arrive ça s'en va
huit ans développe plusieurs fois pour
plusieurs personnes de plusieurs façons
différentes puis l'espèce de du moins la
vision que hollywood nous donne de
l'amour avec un grand a qui exige une
fois pour quelqu'un l'homme sort de ces
choses là
moi j'ai l'impression que ça fait que 4
est en amour à quelqu'un tu veux tu va
accepter tout parce que l'amour c'est la
valeur ultime tir puis j'ai comme le
feeling que c'est perpétuer aussi par la
fiction puis temps papa dans ton livre
de ce sommet c'est quelque chose qui est
certain c'est sûrement partir de là que
j'en ai j extrapolé dans mon dans la
pensée mais c'est que j'ai l'impression
que c'est comme une vision décalée d'un
sentiment qui est humain truc je trouve
que c'est super intéressant ta réflexion
puis c'est justement je lui aussi et
j'en parle dans mon livre sur la section
sweet home alabama que on dirait que il
faut absolument que l'amour ça soit
juste une fois
puis quand même un peu seul dans les
personnages masculins parce que indiana
jones mais finalement son seul à mot ce
thème est rien
jeudi c'est comme si il ya une faille
pour 1 go 1 go pour une fille pic à
presque tout le reste c'est des
expériences mais on nous montre toujours
aussi le sentiment amoureux
un peu comme une anxiété fait fi des
feux d'artifice souvent comme un feu qui
brûle un feu qui brûle ça fait mal -
c'est alors que ça a été long mois dans
ma vie à ce que je découvre que
finalement là c'est l'amour qui me
faisait du bien ce test était douce they
can puis que c'était pas et avait pas d
des explosions en tout les jours c'est
des explosions ça fait mal cette
ressource est crée un stress c'est comme
ça on dirait qu'on veut nous apprendre
que l'amour c'est du stress
c'est une cabale sol ouaip et comment à
quel point que les amours impossibles
sont glorifiés aussi donc c'est comme si
on se dit m justement comment parler de
l'acaa est amoureuse de la personne qui
veut pas et là ça va être ma quête je
veux je veux trouver cette personne ne
pleut la personal mais kaka vomir wheels
a fait une explosion ça va être ça va
être ce que j'attendais finalement tout
est un peu comme les films c'est un
vieux film avec dustin hoffman nautica
qui réussit à aller la chercher au
mariage
nous on avait eu ça analysé dans nos
cours de cinéma la concordia c'est comme
la scène de la fin c'est dustin hoffman
puis la fille qui s'est vraiment pas de
battre leur des gradués et puis
quelqu'un qui finalement les deux se
ramasse dans le taxi afin se regarde la
radio qu'est-ce qu'on me lefaure lucky
ones à qui je pense que ce re d'arles
pour moi c'est ce qui démontre qu est ce
qui arrive après un grand geste
seulement comme cela fut quoi à long
terme c'est la finale avait dit oui
est ce que vous seriez regarder comme ça
tout ça après ces jeunes amoureux de
seconde à mais on avait reçus justement
comment café anne marie ménard quitté
qui était batelière
c'est légitime et c'est souvent on
mélange de man à meaux et stress le dis
parce que justement les gens de
papillons combat là je vais papillon
pour ces personnes lettre est une boule
de stress dans le band pour que parce
que justement c'est si souvent si les
relations les relations plus intenses et
souvenirs à l'action un peu malsaine un
peu un peu toxique qui testait ce pays
où est-ce que tu dois travailler deux
fois plus fort puisqu'il c'est moi
moyens des lycées relation là que j'ai
besoin de recourir de quelque chose
d'une journée se termine d'un état non
plus tu es comme tout le temps qu'on
dise il compliqué c'était comme à puce
gsm comme toi je me rendis compte que
crime dans le fond tout le temps parce
que c'est trop trop disent ils s'épient
justement titre t'opposes danton et ses
passagers mr beke qui est vraiment comme
ceux où un autre personnage de haydn qui
qui lui c'est comme il communique t il
ya une vie stable
il veut s'engager ce type c'est du crime
ce très bon participe ici comme vu comme
platz tu sais si pis si ce quidam agents
société c'est que qu'une relation saine
relation somme toute tranquille sur une
relation qui voit bien qu'il ya pas de
gros des gros bonnets bretagne russie
c'est comme si c'est juste comme ça va
bien aux jo c'est comme considéré comme
plate
oui puis je trouve que c'est dommageable
pour vous les gossip pied il ya plein de
khimki monde se tient entre autres que
et ont de la misère à se reconnaître en
eux mêmes dans les faits dans les
fictions en tant que bongo gentil c'est
que les bongo gentils sont comme des
pains comme justement plate bon pour le
rôle du meilleur ami ou de l'ex plate
que te réussit à attend attend attend
sauver atteindre key et c'est dans mon
essai il ya tout à une espèce de
questions le bi goût est depuis moi je
veux dire que mon essai c'est pour 1 et
parce que moi j'essaie de démontrer que
cette question le big wedding c'est tel
personnage tel personnage pour moi c'est
un faux dilemme c'est que c'est comme
s'il n'y a pas d'autre choix
c'est comme si on peut pas être bégué
d'un ours et c'est comme ça on peut pas
être un un autre affaire c'est comme
s'il y avait pas de troisième voie c'est
comme juste sousse ou telle espèce
d'amour extraordinaire puis l'amour
ordonnant arty qui que c'est qu'il faut
toujours montrer que quelqu'un qui il ya
beaucoup de monde au site et j'entendais
goût dire et dunst un mot alors qu'aiden
saint ghislain et puis on dirait qu'à
chaque fois qu'un personnage masculine t
scène ben c'est soit un mou soit les
gens disent c'est comme frauduleux j'ai
écouté tout un un podcast sur fraude au
hockey puis frodo il ya eu une grosse
affaire comme quoi y étudier le thé
comme maire je parle le seigneur des
anneaux meti ok il pourrait être gay pis
ça serait super cool pour lui mais
pourquoi faut absolument qu'il soit gay
si ce test est un personnage masculin
sein qui soit gay où qu'ils soient de
polly et moi je m'en fous mais pourquoi
si un personnage masculin
il ya une masculinité seigne est capable
de prendre un ami garçons dans ses bras
et que tu y es gentil que finalement si
ils soient pas nécessairement bon à la
bataille mais pourquoi il faut
absolument que ce soit un personnage gay
c'est donc moi et je me dis à chaque
fois qu une masculinité scène qui nous
est présenté ben finalement c'est autant
un personnage qui est un petit peu
ridiculisé par les autres ce pee ou qui
est considéré comme pour un vrai que je
suis en train de l'est aussi laissé de
lys planque pour l'amour des hommes puis
ça je trouve ça super intéressante et sa
réflexion justement sur des hommes je
demandé les modèles qui leur sont
présentés tous sopi qui commet que je
demande qu'un cas une masculinité scène
et présenter ben c'est comme quasiment
comme pour un vrai groupe
c'est comme si hayden dans sex and the
city mais pour les gens alors que c'est
un good
et synthés et à le tromper avec son ex
puis finalement qu'à qui reprennent
ensemble et accepte qu'à soigner avec
son ex limoux c'est à cause de toi à
cause de lui les puzzles ou de mac os
qui est pas jaloux c'est comme si ce jeu
me pose des questions là dessus puis je
me dis faut que les que la masculinité
scène est aussi une représentation
représentation positive si je trouve que
c'est important pour les goûts d'abord
c'est d'avoir cessé ses modèles ses
modèles hop ça soit peau comme dénigrer
ou dénigrants je trouve que ce serait
moi je trouve que ça fait partie de ce
qui serait le fun de démontrer puisque
on bulle avec mon essai le cpo de faire
une espèce de liste d'épicerie le hockey
on n'y est pas on va coacher l'équipe
qui gagne c'est fabuleux
ouais c'est ça non que ces femmes là
existe le garde j'ai lu écouté lowen
monster be j'ai eu une belle discussion
avec mon homme après de ce que met-on ok
maintenant y aurait pu ne pas embrasser
la fille ou tout mais ça veut pas dire
que ça n'existe pas ça veut juste dire
plus de diversité dans la rue nous est
présenté ici c'est de trouver des idées
des fois le si je le vois que met-on on
se parle entre créateurs que les gens -
mais le ce a redonné des histoires plate
onesta puis je comprends l'anxiété que
sacrée parce que on est habitué à
certaines façons de raconter des
histoires puis à certains codes mais je
pense qu'il ya moyen de trouver des
nouvelles des petits je parle beaucoup
de liberté de création dans mon essai
épi jeunesse je me dis je souhaite que
la liberté de création
on se réfléchir à tout cela ne l'atteint
pas j'espère que ça nous aide à trouver
d'une des nouvelles idées qui comme moi
j'aime beaucoup dans les dernières
années le blink à ce titre je me dis
ainsi le fun c'est vrai on n'aurait
jamais pensé à ceux avancés de deux
frères une série historique qui est pas
nécessairement et en accord avec
l'histoire
mais pourquoi pauvreté comme vois pas
faire du blanc casting ceci c'est
tellement le fun
la diversité puis à la limite on s'en
fout le ticket que les faits historiques
le soin poète et ce n'est jamais de
toute façon d'allier mais dans dix ans
tout le temps romain facchetti moi je
trouve qu'elle comme il ya quand même de
l'espoir mais deux choses n'a pas à ce
que d'ici pour venir à lord of the rings
j'ai vu ton regard s'allume et kg par
jour
ça vient me chercher mais frau d'autres
boivent parce que serra faudrait six
mois on rend le personnage principal qui
ôte il ya aucune allusion au yoyo qu'une
aucun levante reste que jamais de
dynamique avec une femme ou avec thé ou
aux amoureux avec personne ses tandis
que met-on sanwi aragon nous y était
mais j'écoutais il ya une chaîne youtube
de ses 2 go qui analyse des films
multiplia analyse le lord of the rings
ses personnages d'aragorn travers le
prisme de la masquer une tite excessif
disque pour sûrs agon s'est comme
l'exemple parfait de d'une bascule tai
chi à l'afrique et qui essaime chiquita
la foule les stéréotypes mais qui qui
celle en même temps parce que t il fort
c'est un combattant il est courageux
surtout si terrà type le con qu'on
accorde le tir ou héros masculin mais
tille et respectueux et des femmes et il
pleure il chante il encourage la femme
allait se battre aux combos avec avec
avec ses épées quelqu'un était pour lui
mais lui qu'il décline les brahma de
manière et gentlemen c pip taquet c'est
ça que c'est intéressant c'est que oui
c'est l'homme parfait
vous visez à être aragon moi très élevé
je suis d'accord avec toi c'est quand
j'analyse mettant à roanne qui s'appelle
wang triste parce que au début à nous
est montrée comme une fille qui se borne
à nanard
après tout les firmes toutes les trop
gore qui a renonce à tous ses privilèges
à elles deux de ses partenaires foccart
annoncé les immortels annonce que le ça
revient beaucoup à ce qu'on demande
personnage féminin de renoncer à soi
même qui avait quelque chose qui
m'énervait aussi par rapport à l'autre
personnage féminin et l'autre y en a 2
je me suis piquée au m1 et owen et wayne
ouais c'est qu'en 4 turbo nomme le aydin
phrasé sais je suis un peu et aucun
homme comme tout bouge pas comme je suis
une femme parce qu'ils voulaient vivre
les ehome la race
j'aime ce qu'a dit sur moi pain cuit
c'est sûr que ça me fais mes shsh comme
cissé c'est comme on voudrait que lé
guerrière puis tout ça pis je me suis
plu c'est quoi qui m'avait énervé mais
je sais comme si je me dis qu'elle avait
paul avait pas lieu à pink a mérité
finalement voilà marché a fini dans la
ligue avec un autre personnage de bouées
pied n'dinga jusque on le voit pas
vraiment les cada hollande
l'infirmerie pleine sarsgaard qui ont un
regard du roi est fini pour mais j'avais
un autre et un autre point à porter qui
était pilote de ligne sur ce qu'ils
l'avaient été après mais je me suis plu
je suis ce que je suis on est plus je
pense vraiment que si c'est vraiment
intéressant par rapport à notre rapport
avec la fiction de comment les codes
interagissent clairement avec et et
j'écoutais j'écoutais adventures in vain
avant il y avait coûté 26 reçu des coups
souvent non mais non non non mais il en
avait coûté le 2 comme le film c'est
trop drôle mais juste à quel point ces
commandes est connecté l'intrigué
principale qui réalise que racing qu'al
qaîda le botteur des dolphins de miami
est devenue une femme puis qu'il s'est
déguisé en femme pour devenir inspecteur
de police le lui embrasser cette femme
lotte la seconde qui réalise que cette
femme est un an
il se met à vomir il brûle son linge
emails des pompes sont là et je mets
dans un baril ils brûlent puybrun crise
il prend un débours toilettes puis joris
pompe la face ça aucun sens mais réalise
qui règne chez un homme qui après ça je
me dis monde amateur c'était le seul
moment que ça se passait finalement plus
tard sont comme dans le dénuement puis
j'arrête tout les policiers de la force
de la force de police qui travaille pour
cette fille legrand fait un homme puis
la s 28 rue la dévoile comme est en
difficulté depuis le tout les policiers
souhaitent à vomir automatiquement
j'applique c'est comme ça aucun sens
l'étude amérique cherchent le il ya une
affaire si je pouvais pas mettre tout
c'est ce qu'ils avaient des affaires
tout type de racisme et d'homophobie mme
puis à moment donné je veux je voulais
pas faire un livre de 300 pages puis des
fois c'est pas ma place de parler de
certaines choses mais j'étais il ya
quelque chose qui s'appelle dans les
grilles d'analysé le no homo piqué qui
se sait dans beaucoup de films dans des
séries télé souvent remarqué que s'il ya
deux personnages masculins qui ont une
interaction qui est un peu trop émotive
ils vont en faire on n'est pas bien on
est poli c'est un homme au style souvent
dans friends introduit une de mes séries
préférées mais chandler peep-toe jouer à
chaque fois qu'ils ont une interaction
un peu plus émotive qui prennent pas
normal c'est le droit d'insérer dans des
brocantes et et de google mail son camp
mais ces bons qui est 100 on le remarque
souvent que c'est comme un gros exemple
de nouveaux moules si ces gens il veut
tellement dément pas avoir embrassé un
garçon laïb reçoivent et la faute la
suisse lave toutes les autres policiers
tck et tout le monde sait au mot pis
c'est triste parce que cette
représentation là aussi ça a des
conséquences c'est moi il ya un jeune
garçon qui me qui s'est confié à
moineaux joppy qui m'a dit moi la
représentation
d'un homme gay dans la fiction samassa a
fait que ça a retardé mon coming out et
même mon acceptation de ma propre
homosexualité parce que je me reconnais
c'est pas piquant le tout ce que tout ce
que tu connais de ta réalité le parce
qu'il y en a pas autour de toi le sait
la fiction mais c'est du sud le 2e -
chaussures mais je me reconnais pas la
dap le ya un décalage qui puissent et
pour ce que c'est important d'avoir une
diversité je pense qu'il ya de plus en
plus de gens qui la demande s'est
diverti cette diversité le puis moi je
suis vraiment d'accord avec ce petit
c'est jeudi un témoin ai-je pas au
dessus des autres
je suis vraiment pas au dessus des
autres dans mon premier livre je le dis
dans mon lit glorifier un amour toxiques
mais aussi dans mes films si je me dis
ah si on dirait que j'aurais pu me
forcer pour la diversité
je vais vous raconter une histoire que
jamais racontée mais moi dans mes
leaders élus j'ai toujours imaginé la
meilleure amie de 4 comme une asiatique
c'est moi je l'imaginais famille
parfaite mais avec deux petites fait
adopter mais j'en parle jamais dans le
mail ivre ce monstre dans mon imaginaire
puis quand on est venu le temps de faire
le film j'ai une se plaint beaucoup de
gens m'ont dit oui mais c'est la vérité
asiatiques
elle en aurait parlé le jeter com -
c'est vrai que ça aurait fait partie de
l'histoire qui décide et non pas parce
88 ça m'est arrivé ce valet de me faire
dire aurélie époque comme swisscom
mais bref
mais jeter comme owasp au foot est que
je l'imaginais de même dans ma tête mais
que dans le fond c'est juste mon
imagination qui était comme ce petit
aujourd'hui ce que les gens demandent
c'est on peut tu avoir la diversité que
sans que ce soit nommé nak muay
finalement mon instinct il était bon
j'aurais pu avoir une meilleure amie de
aurélie qu'était asiatique sans que ce
soit nommé jamais ce soit injuste mais
juste
livres pour le nommer c'est juste que tu
peux le voir les lignes
je sais que c'est pas dans un film c'est
une description physique j'imagine que
des treks soit physiquement des
personnages parce que je me suis
toujours on dirait que j'ai toujours eu
cet instant un look tout le monde
pouvait se reconnaître puis moi quand je
lis le pissot ça vient de moi comme
lectrice de je déteste qu'on me
décrivent un personnage souvent le gosse
tout un grand brun de 1 mètre 80 de
hockey un mic 92,6 cela c'est la
grandeur que les personnages masculins
en vison brin naïf avec moi c'était
comme quelque chose que je ne voulais
pas faire ce mais bref pour ceux que
j'avais sont intactes mais je me dis
mais oui mais oui comme si tu veux
mettre un personnage handicap est obligé
de parler de son struggled dette
handicapée
t'es pas obligé de c'est comme une
personne qui est asiatique où une
personne noire où tout pour que je parle
de tous si une personne qui qui qui
égaie 20 obligé de parler de tout ça
peut être juste normalisé fait que je
pense que si je trouve ça l'fun parce
qu'on dirait qu'on est rendu le pendre
est que la conversation a mené des
batailles un personnage marginalisés on
n'est pas obligé de parler de sa
marginalité
on peut le faire c'est des fois je me
questionne tout comme dans le film que
j'ai écrite si j'ai un personnage
marginalisés puis sa marginalité fait un
peu partie mon histoire plus au début
j'étais comme un sécurité comme art
c'est place j'aurai mes seuls intégrité
comme dans une histoire normal mais en
même temps même amener quelque chose
mais dans le même film j'en ai un autre
personnage marginalisés que possible
histoire par toute fin quand même temps
il faut être capable de doser il faut
pas trop se mettre de barrières mais je
pense que c'est important d'amener de la
diversité sans que la diversité fasse
partie des enjeux combien de films est
ce qu'il ya un personnage homosexuel
mais que c'est l'ami gay qui est ultra
ultra extraverti piketty est vraiment
c'est aussi le bilan y vivent avec
succès
c'est souvent seul souvent la difficulté
ou ou la caricature métier mettons la
série c'est maintenant les séries tu
vois une belle série qui se font sur
netflix
on le sent ça change et réflexion c'est
justement le web était quand même blanc
le plus beau métier mais ton s'expliquer
les chaînes je trouvais que tous les
trucs t7 cette semaine je trouve quand
même qui aimait tant c'est très
diversité culturelle qui justement aussi
durci sexuelle ya là pour qui tu es
l'homosexualité c'est comme au spa tout
chaud d'autre que oui fakty au moins au
sein du plus que représentant de chacune
des affaires le tipi les différentes
versions vision de la marginalité
mais je sais tu que je te dise tu es t
je pense que le mot clé là dedans c'est
cécilia qui représente des relations qui
sont toxiques
c'est qu'il faut parler glorifié dans le
fond c'est parce que l'hexagone après
tous les maux qui sont populaires fille
et un fils moi ce qu'on voit des
relations de violentes de violence ou
qu'ils aient des conflits mais que que
la morale si pau aubay s'est enfoncé tu
es mon fils était sale el sol béton
c'est ce prix des dram dans son maquis
des comédies dramatiques souvent le
médecin mettons
c'est définitivement un drame de
violentes scènes de violence mé i qui
finit pas ob on va bâtir ont fini
ensemble puis dans le fond c'est pas
grave on marche terry de montrer si
c'est pas de censure et ceux où 200 soit
au contraire c'est c'est de paul et
glorifié fonseka s'est montrée et avec
un fond rose du sud du crémage puis des
belles chansons tout ce puits que tu es
un apn
mais après quelque chose qui vraiment
tout comme que quand tu regardes studio
avec toulon mais pour ceux qui étaient
j'ai pas vu cette année city fixée au 2
vraiment dire mais c'est selon ce que
met-on en lisant les ans on essaie on la
retient c'est que c'est vraiment la fin
il pragmatique c'est parce que si mais
pas eu de faille le jeudi on a retiré
comme conclusion que comme tu peux pas
agir de même pu t'en sors tipi genre qui
a pas de conséquence être impunément
mais vu que finalement à la fin c'est
comme au balafon je t'aime c'est piqué
cox a fini ensemble c'est comme un genre
c'est un coup d'essai c'est un courage
et une enfant il fini ça finit bien pour
lui qui était qu un peu comme un modèle
qui est tellement répétitif que tu finis
par te dire mais éventuellement et finir
par marcher puis moi je donne beaucoup
l'exemple de la machine à sous 6 4
devant une machine à jour le 10 mai
d'argent tu mets de l'argent
maintenant j'ai un beau podium ça va
payer ça vaut payer ça va payer
puis ça représente l'investissement que
tu mère dans une relation puis
éventuellement ça va finir par marcher
si le modèle qui tu es toujours envoyer
c'est que dans une réelle dans une
relation où il ya une cale tous à l'art
impossible ne puis que ça finit par à
piennes mais tu t'attends ou à piennes
que le happy ont aussi fait partie de la
violence de la violence conjugale
ça s'appelle la période lune de miel
c'est que dans le cycle de la violence
dit est dit l'amour au début de la
tension de la con
flic qui survient qui après ceux de la
justification puis après surtout la
réconciliation dans la réconciliation
ces bons souvent la personne qui a été
violente vont essayer de justifier va
essayer de transformer un peu l'effet
fac l'autre personne a va se remettre en
question et rome ainsi j'ai sûrement ma
part de responsabilité la nafaqa vaudois
veut développer une certaine confusion
mais il ya une lune de miel aussi a
failli à la personne va se servir de la
de sentiments amoureux du début pour
recréer une lune de miel
enfin c'est comme si un moment donné il
ya des gens qui deviennent accros à cet
esprit de muriaux de lune de miel
c'est ce qui fait un peu le cycle de la
violence parce que parce que ce cette
lune de miel qui revient un peu au feu
d'artifice dont tu parlais tantôt de
toute lisse et sentiment qu'on apprend à
reconnaître comme des signaux amoureux
ben là ça devient quasiment même comme
une drogue
pitt et quentin possède drogue l'eau
parce que tu as un amour saint tite d'un
amour ou yapo dis des gros des gros buzz
c'est comme si douce et calme c'est une
mer calme tu y mets l'eau quand survient
avec la mer agitée puisque ça te fait
des gros des grosses vagues dans ton
coeur ballotté comme tu deviens comme
accro à ce peloton comme quand
finalement la relation est au beau fixe
c'est comme si en a qui vont essayer de
créer des problèmes pour créer des
vagues pour ramener l'espèce de feu
d'artifice qui a pu cesser dans le fond
le problème non
moi ce que tu décris le je me reconnais
beaucoup parce que j'ai déjà vécu un
début vingtaine de types stay exactement
ce type i
si ce texte est exactement ce que le pit
dit tout le temps
après le prochain problème quand on va
régler ce problème là un kit elle
détaillé quand l obstacle qui fait que
le en ce moment c'est de la marque vont
être réglé ça bien ali parce que cette
personne le cas que quand ça va bien est
parfaite si souvent du monde que leurs
beaux côtés sont tellement beau c'est
souvent du monde super intelligent du
monde super drôle de monstre intense pas
c'est pas parfait mais quand ça va bien
ça va bien mais quand ça va mal ça va
mal tabarnak par exemple pis tout le
temps on va passer par dessus puis ça
finit pas bien aller parce qu'on est
fait pour être ensemble parce que c'est
tellement intense puisque mambo
observons aussi de femmes à ce que la
vérité c'est qu'à nos jeunes damiers non
c'est jallet recommence tout le temps
petit jaune sur jean a dit quelque chose
par rapport à ceux dans mon livre jones
urgence puisque le aug et chercheur en
violence conjugale et vous pourriez la
recevoir on en est vraiment intéressant
sonia lupien mais des violences
conjugales qui moi j'ai adoré par les
leurs a été libérateur pour moi le mais
elle dit
on n'aime pas quelqu'un pour ses défauts
on aime quelqu'un pour ses qualités qui
s'est souvent on sent coupable d'aimer
quelqu'un qui nous fait du mal mais on
devrait pas se sentir capable d'aimer
l'amour c'est beau on devrait juste
regarder que une percée l'autre personne
qu'est ce que cette personne le fait
avec notre amour qui est pas correct ou
hulu com être notre relation à le virer
métier les raisons pourquoi tu aimes la
personne c'est justement pour les
qualités ses propos c'est pas pour les
défauts pouvoir était de blanc mais
l'amour ou de ce blanc met soi-même
d'avoir pardonné d'avoir voulu plus il
faut juste reconnaître que les signes
qui démontrent qu'on est dans une
relation qui est prescrit pas bonne pour
nous mais il faut arrêter tout c'est
comme si tu prend de la drogue que c'est
pas bon pour toi puisque tu t'en rends
compte un moment donné faut taxer que ça
serait pas bon pour toi pour ta santé
puis tout ce qu'il faut que t'arrêtes
même si c'est super difficile dit il et
pourquoi tu t'ennuies de la drogue mais
c'est pour les bons côtés de la drogue
c'est pas pour les côtés ou qu'ils aient
finalement volé l'emmène veille c'est
exactement
ayant déjà vécu une relation de même où
j'avais où j'avais je lui avais mis pied
un engrenage qui que j'étais embarqué
profond plus apprécié et justement c'est
tout tu lis tout l'est m
tout ce qu'on écrit le thé la confusion
de sable blanc met soi-même
et cerise au lit de son entourage tout
ce tous existe des menaces des suicides
tout ce qui existait tout c'est elle
mais mettons ayant vu que ce jeu mais
dit maintenant je mets mes limites c'est
beaucoup plus puis je les ai pas mal
plus aiguisé ma tante et qui est un
autre des vibrations ou est ce que la
personne fait souvent été très commenté
ainsi un humour très chouette pikine
s'épiler des dogmes était pour elle
c'était juste une manière de faire du
mot peace est juste personnes une
personne peut tjrs et extravertie là au
dessus de cépie moi comment je recevais
ses apprentis ça me faisait pas sentir
bien et j'ai pu le juger je vais le dire
de suite fait clair c'est comme
quelqu'un quand me dissoudre
si on pouvait sentir bien et puis d'un
an pour se soucier laisser convoquer ses
mais le ca continue tu mets ton elle met
de l'eau dans son vin mais continue de
sonner juste comme ce pianiste est comme
moi je me sentais pas bien parce que
parce qu'il a course à cause de ce puits
elle sentait pas bien non plus parce
qu'ils avaient l'impression justement
cuche shut down et comment elle était
tout le temps piqué qui est ouverte et
qu'il fallait le temps qu'a marche sur
des oeufs
parce qu'être cette affaire qui fait que
j'ai l'impression que dans cette colo
step aux personnes qui tu es coupable
c'est juste qu'on était deux personnes
qui étaient incompatibles s'arrêter là
d'après ce que tu me racontes sait faire
des blagues d'une grande
ça fait vraiment partie de la
personnalité d'une personne c'est si les
blagues grasses métiers autres que
temouchent je pense maintenant à
employant une à l'extérieur là dessus
qu'ils étaient juste personnel c'est une
bonne personne ne touche pas vraiment
jusqu'à la croix je te crois mais tu
sais juste que quand tu dis à quelqu'un
que quelque chose te fais de la peine un
mois selon moi ça fait partie d'une
résolution de conflits pitt d'empathie
je pense pas je pense pas que tu
essayais de la contrôler et de pas dire
des choses que ce que je comprends de ce
que tu me racontes sais que tu m'étonnes
limites claires que ça te faisais de
l'apn pitié je pense que il faut qu'on
apprenne dans une résolution de conflits
que si on fait de la peine à quelqu'un
mais c'est peu et on peut regarder en
soi même ses épis accepté est en train
de faire de la peine à cette personne
sauf que faut vous différencier et
istres legault dit ça me fait de la
peine kapsach avec tes amis leur manning
a scoré etc
mais si c'est des blagues que tout sans
dénigrer et c'est moi ça m'arrivait
aussi qu'avec mon chum c'est des fois je
moi j'étais habitué avec des gagne 2 go
qui je faisais ça m'arrivait de faire
des blagues
c'est un peu baveuse un peu dénigrante
eu le moment donné mon ami m'a dit et
c'est j'aime pas ce genre de blagues
l'outil plus jeter comme un michael je
pense que mon plus jeune j'aime pas ce
finalement plus j'aime pas seulement
faire briller en fait pourquoi tu sais
ça m'a fait avoir une réflexion je pense
qu'on a le droit des fois tu sais une
rencontre entre deux personnes est une
rencontre on a chacun nos blessures on a
chacun notre passé on a chacun
je pense qu'il faut avoir à apprendre à
avoir de l'empathie envers l'autre
c'est l'autre personne est assez
honnêtes pour te dire est ce que ça me
fait de la peine
je pense qu'on peut avoir de l'empathie
pisé et moi je laime cette personne je
pense que je peux essayer de faire
attention à ceux c'est vraiment pas une
affaire de goût fait hippiques un qui
fait ce bien kiffé ce taux raison des
fois il ya deux personnes qui deviennent
toxiques ensemble pour info s'en rendre
compte pis c'est des fois ça peut
c'est peut-être que cette fille là la
rencontre un coq lui aussi fait ce genre
de blagues laupies à la dérange pop
higuain tant mieux pour eux autres into
you raison de mettre des limites puis de
dire bye finalement moi tout ça ça me
rejoint - ce genre d'affaires le mais je
pense aussi quand on a un réel désir
d'évoluer avec l'autre personne
mais on en a le droit de réfléchir à
certaines nos comportements pièce a
essayé d'évoluer au contact de l'autre
sans changer sa propre identité parce
qu'une affaire que je me dis moi c'est
que il faut pas renoncer à soi même pour
l'amour mais en même temps ça se peut
que des choses qu'on fait par réflexe ou
parce que ça fait partie de la sphère
qu'on fait depuis longtemps petit topic
et on peut se dire et finalement le tuer
comme c'est pas c'est vrai que c'est pas
cool qui comme ok je donne un exemple de
mon propre groupe
montsho mlle c'est quelqu'un de très
pragmatique tout ce mois là je tends mon
cerveau il marche à 100 milles à l'heure
et qui tu me pose une question là puis
je vais te répondre du tac au tac monde
sommes des fois ça prend quatre secondes
qui moi pendant ce 4 secondes l'autre
gauche 6 comme pauvre lui devra répondre
si je me dis pauvre lui ai dit c'est
pourquoi répondrons-nous tu sais pas
trop quoi alors que lui il réfléchit
pour bien répondre à la question
[ __ ] moment donné il me disait petit
quand serait pas ma place le plus quand
m
chiche j'essaye vraiment de m'améliorer
mais s'est pas prononcé à moi-même que
de d'arrêter de répondre à la place de
ma vie que je renonce pas moi même et je
me dis je veux m'améliorer comme un être
humain je vais accepter que des fois les
gens ça prend quatre secondes ses avants
qui répondent à la question alors que
moi pendant que la personne est en train
de poser une question je veux répondre
c'est des fois je laisse même pas la
personne fini avec ça c'est quelque
chose que je me dis et je peux
m'améliorer
ces soldes phone d'une relation
amoureuse c'est que tu peux t'améliorer
comme un être humain
absolument d'une main puis chanté
relation c'est vraiment aussi un miroir
sur soi-même justement pilier de devoir
un peu on voit notre avait raté puis on
voit surtout qu'on a besoin de
travailler de cépie cccc faut pas été
insultés de ce type ont grandi en grade
à chaque fois la difficulté si je suis
quelqu'un qui est dans une relation qui
taxe
des fois tu as l'impression que c'est
toute l'afrique
c'est pour ça que c'est tellement dur
quand tu es dans de le voir contre est
facile à dire mais sort de se laisser
comme est ce parce que la td fréquenté
dedans tu penses que ceci si je moi
change se savoir que rex je souhaite
qu'ils disent ils dans une relation
toxique le sait que la personne à passe
constamment de la mort a lancé
mais le jeudi avec des gros mots mais
c'est que mettons la personne à vrai
dire et comme j'adore ton sourire et
j'adore tes yeux
mais sam gosse vraiment été cheveux cgt
comme la même mais elle aime pas mes
cheveux je vais pas changer mes cheveux
etc
ça doit être moi qui pour corps et que
tu es comme cefac timea même parce
qu'elle m'a dit mon sourire de mes yeux
mais un maudit mes cheveux petit de ça
ça ça peut s'appliquer plein d'affaires
de la personnalité le thé mais dès que
tracts et comme tout temps dans un
espèce de toute confusion des genres et
tim est on si je reviens à sex and the
city ou même moins des choses que j'ai
vécu dans ma vie tout en mettant des
personnes qui veulent pas être en
relation peloter comme mais c est ce que
t es ce que tu penses que tu va vouloir
être en relation un jour avec moi donc
tu sais plus ce que t'es pas intéressé à
moi type la personne mettez j't'adore je
me suis passé du temps avec toi ta ta ta
mais je sais pas si le jeu pas prêt mais
peut-être bientôt pilotes et comme ok
mais depuis j'ai des sentiments pour toi
mais je pars moureu mais peut-être que
ça va
peloter commun mais peut-être que ça va
arriver un jour prudent parce que sam 2
6 tc beaucoup comme ça tu sais que tu as
été j'ai des sentiments mais je sais pas
mais peut-être métier j'aime ce qu'on
pense du temps sans métier je veux pas
me marier pleut il revient et bien
mariés plus petit mais mayence parce
qu'il voulait pas se marier avec moi
aussi fins que celles et hot confusion
qui était là la psychologue dans mon
livre cadix et fois apprendre à
déterminer notre méthode bien attrition
sont confus si on sent constamment
coupable
on est tout le temps en train de se
remettre en question de notre propre
réalité tout ce qui se dessine que ça
veut dire que c'est peut-être une
relation toxique t son sens bien mais le
problème selon moi c'est que quand on se
sent bien souvent c'est qu'on pense
qu'on n'est pas amoureux c'est parce
qu'ils se plient pas cette affaire avec
ses looks il faut essayer de réajuster
un petit peu de notre perception de ckoi
une relation amoureuse c'est quoi
l'amour comme un suspect en question par
question qui face à la réponse une fois
je parle anne fille qui était vraiment
tanné de vivre des relations toxiques
j'essaie de parler de ce piano dit je
pas prêt d'arrêter les montagnes russes
fac et la halle avait mal mais à voulait
encore des montagnes russes
c'est ça se peut dans vie que tu sois
dans une période qui veut ça mais c'est
moi mon souhait en fait mon impression
c'est que c'est comme on disait tantôt
tu sais que c'est un modèle qu'on nous
envoie que c'est ce truc fun des
montagnes russes amoureuse mais si on
envoie un modèle c'est ma question j'ai
pas pu y répondre mais que si on envoie
des modèles 5 plus souvent peut-être
qu'on va trouver ça beau finalement ces
modèles peut-être qu'on va avoir envie
de vivre ces choses là qui sont qui sont
belles piques qui sont pas basés sur des
montagnes russes amoureuse justement
c'est fascinant je veux je veux qu'on
aborde ne rien enfin avec toi une dire
parce que je sais que c'est quelque
chose qui touche de tuer coûté 6 pire si
un parti qui gagnent trois titres
étaient des gardes tu défends c'est pas
près des séparations on avançait
toujours ayant toutes été depuis
longtemps hésité végétarisme arrive des
fois des fromages en général tous testés
les baleines je crois que tu as fait
allen c'est moi qui dansent et si le
baril qui mon idole tous les côtés oui
je l'écouté bon ça a fait une grosse
discussion avec mon chum parce que les
profanes de documentaires à la base
netflix parce que c'est souvent ce qui
évidemment ce documentaire le il ya
beaucoup de faits qui sont polis préfet
tout à fait entre autres est bon les
scientifiques trop la plupart disent y
dénote un très bon problème c'est à dire
que la surpêche c'est vraiment un
problème qui moelleux j'écris un livre
documentaire sur les baleines depuis
2016 qui va sortir cet automne et c'est
quelque chose qui me touche énormément
ric o'barry et entre autres je sais pas
si vous savez c'est kim heger tout en un
petit peu de recovery dans une
parenthèse
ric o'barry merida et lui si c'était un
entraîneur de dauphins ils ont imprégné
flipper c'est une émission so dans les
années 70 mais flipper c'est un dauphin
est lui un moment donné flipper s'est
suicidé devant lui comment pourquoi qui
sait que l'épreuve ten femelles à se
suicider c'est que les dauphins respire
de façon volontaire puis elle finalement
un respect profond était en dépression
on lui demandait trop comme dauphin pour
les besoins de l'émission est lui qui a
vu quand j'ai vu ça et il
et toutes les larmes de son corps et le
dis j'ai participé à ceux qui à cause de
flipper il ya eu tout le tourisme de
dauphin qui a commencé à tirer nage avec
les dauphins
ces affaires lui qui lui a dit moi j'ai
participé à une industrie le que je vois
que je veux m'engager à détruire je vois
consacré ma vie à me faire pardonner de
ce à quoi j'ai participé qui est rendu à
un activisme un activiste pour sauver
les dauphins à travers le monde
ils dénoncent plusieurs affaires dont la
chasse aux dauphins parce que pour nager
avec un dauphin souvent une chasse est
fait on le dit dans dans six pays russie
entre autres
puis la chasse souvent ça va tuer comme
20 dauphin pour nom pognon aussi bon et
d'ailleurs dans le documentaire
s'inspire ici le olivier s'est caché les
les yeux quand les baleines sorte oui
moi je pleure et à grosse genou
je pleurais mon chat me coller lui
voulait pas regarder donc
ric o'barry c'est lui dans le
documentaire de fact checking que montre
ça m'a fait ce que bon on s'attaque à à
des organismes qui essaie de préserver
les anciens associés c'est comme un peu
un problème il ya plusieurs chiffres ou
six qui sont pas livrés shift bref
plusieurs faits comme ceux qui sont
tranquilles et pour le bien dans le fond
de sa propre de sa propre conclusion
dans le fond puis lui sa conclusion
c'est que il faut devenir vegan puis ce
que les gens disent c'est que dans le
fond ça met beaucoup de poids sur le
consommateur marty mois chez genre à
dire consommer si voter le thé donc se
retirer de cette industrie là pour moi
c'est quitter dans mes recherches sur
les baleines moi aussi j'ai je suis
arrivé à la même conclusion pas de
devenir vegan mais même si c'est mon
choix moi mais que les filets de pêche
c'est vraiment une bonne une cause très
importante de
deux morts deux balles yens soit plus
lect trafic maritime
le trafic maritime ça fait que les
baleines ils changent c'est isner ben
oui lyon lescoules leur école
localisation et tout devient tout
mélanger fac c'est probablement pour
ceux qui avaient une baleine à montréal
pourtant passé tout le monde sait que
moi ou c'est ce que j'ai appris le sait
que faire des soldes et ben ça c'est un
appel à la haine c'est du spectacle
souvent notre rapport aux animaux est
tellement bizarre que on pense qu'une
baleine via montréal puis qui est là
pour notre bon plaisir de nous faire un
spectacle s'est passé dans le langage c
c comme ce que les gens décrivait au
label n en fait un spectacle ce matin
tenant est en train d'appeler à l'aide
de ses hits il s'est dit iphone romney
ou le fait que ce que je suis passionnée
que tu parles de ça ça me touche émotive
mal mais ces documents par le haut qui
c'est comme si mais c'est mon homme lui
est pas d'accord avec m et on est ce que
la fin justifie les moyens lui c'est
c'est ce qui se demander est ce que on
doit mentir aux gens pour faire changer
des choses mais dieu seul bémol mais
chut le les statistiques j'en ai rien à
faire dans six villes moyennes ma femme
et moi si je t'ai comme tout non mais
parce que les images sont pas un
mensonge
ces mois là il n'y aurait pas un son il
répond une infographie qui aurait pas
une statistique ma perception du
documentaire aurait pas changé le débat
qu'on a eu on monte un petit mois
c'était un pustch techno il y aurait eu
j'aurais écouté sur le sens stats comme
samson sans narration il y aurait rien
il a changé la perception du
documentaire mais il ya aussi comme
étant ric o'barry iliad il ya dit que
les laits entre autres parce que j'étais
allé voir ben oui il y avait pas ce que
beaucoup de gens qui ont participé aux
deux comme documentaire était pas
content puis je suis allé voir ce que
mon fric
oh oui cody qui a dit que c'était un
documentaire important mais lui ric
o'barry avait fait le documentaire de
cove que je vous que davide astori
saucisses fait pleurer d'ailleurs je me
suis demandé s'il y avait certaines
images de 6 pi russie qui avait pas été
fournies par l'équipe de ricco bah oui
parce qu'il y avait des images un peu
solaire mais bref
ric o'barry emile documentaire mais ils
disaient qu'est ce qui était un petit
peu plat dans le documentaire c'est
qu'il ya un peu un racisme est asiatique
c'est à dire que iodé groupe activis
asiatiques
donc si chacun cette critique par
rapport aux documentaires ces genres et
les êtres les asiatiques ne sont pas que
le seul problème donc ses sauts c'était
un petit peu un problème pige ses jetons
je suis moitié je me disais bon ok mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya des quelques nuances
aurait pu être fait que c'est à dire que
bon il ya des groupes activistes
asiatiques qui essaie de contrer ce qui
se passait en asie maintenant moi de
savoir qu'il ya des peuples indigènes
qui crèvent de faim à cause de la
surpêche puisqu'ils sont obligés faire
la pêche illégale et de participer à de
la torture comme ceux animal c'est
humaine maillot quelque chose qui
coupent les ailerons des requins et le
cas d'un parti ou que ça se passe dans
le monde peu importe c'est où
peu importe c'est quoi la statistique
peu importe s'il est seul requin qui
sont morts c'est ce que j'ai vu à
l'écran mais donc c'est ça la vérité et
le passé pour moi mais moi c'est pour
moi moi c'était un petit peu ce fait
comme on avait un débat un peu là tu
piges comprenait les points d'olivier py
lui comprenait les miens aura construit
on se respecte elle adore mois moi je me
dis qui je disais olivier qui était je
comprends tout la science que la science
est longue on essaye de mettre des
mesures en ce moment que tu es les
mesures mais les mesures ça va prendre
combien temps si on respecte toutes les
petites mettons d'attendre les peaux
siens piles et les règlements basé sur
des études tata mais ça va prendre
combien de temps il faut un
il faut qu'on soulève kits hygiène 180°
le htc va mais maintenant ça prend ça
prend un faux compte et on ne sait pas
c'est pas un secret c'est pas la
première fois qu'on entend qu'en 2050
des océans risquent d'être vide le web
et ses soucis c'est une affaire qui
affecte équipe qui est assez bon c'est
pas tout à fait le même si 2500 même si
2006 s'est passé ce temps des bourgeois
de même atteindre enfin le changement
moi je moi je
moi j'étais je me dis qu'il y en a
beaucoup qui disent aussi c'est pas
réaliste que les gens deviennent weygand
puis sochaux d'accord c'est comme on
dirait le moyen découragement par
rapport à se retirer
il ya une partie de moi que de l'espoir
mais une partie de moi qui manque de
sport pythie moi je disais à tout le
monde pendant la pandémie le hémois
d'être vegan ça m'a aidé pendant la
pandémie et je me suis tu occupes du
tofu des lentilles j'avais un million de
recettes combien ça peut faire existe au
futur mettis du poulet ça c'est plus bon
après trois jours pitié en plus excuser
c'est trop le shc l'activiste en moi tu
rigoles autant pour les amants toxiques
chez nuance est supposé j'ai trouvé ma
séance qu'ils aient mais on a tout
appris aussi par rapport aux zones
hausse par rapport au fait que c'est les
pandémies
jeudi il va en avoir de plus en plus de
la déforestation de notre proximité avec
les animaux puis bon si vous sur ceux
liés à l'industrie il m'a alimentaire
achille l'industrie agro alimentaire
d'animaux moussa fadiga d'outils comme
moi là toute la famille c'est là je te
suivrai iloki à longueil le sait
puisqu'il y en a qui disait il
jean luc qui sont comme fruits fruits
pour les chevreuils qui ont de la peine
pitié tata tape ces scientifiques que
c'est mieux de les euthanasier
ok ok parfait mais le problème c'est pas
cette situation là le problème c'est que
on déforeste pour faire des condos que
ces animaux là non plus aucune place ou
à les chiffres us qui a presque au nom
on est comme un bébé et l'eau il s'en
viennent dans nos pères ou est ce qu'on
veut faire notre marge du mangement volé
tué son fils et l'attique l'attique le
ya un problème mais c'est à cause de ça
c'est à cause qu on déforeste pour faire
des condos on déforeste parce qu'on fait
c'est comme et l'agriculture
industrielle c'est ça les doigts parce
que même si maintenant qu'on décès de
s'attarder aux condos là au final 110%
la déforestation mondiale c'est pour les
terres agricoles du dirty le problème
îlot dans notre phase i love ses
soixante dix pour ça c'est ce qu'ils ont
fait rien du tout l amazonie qui brûle
on est à tout le monde tout le monde est
triste mais est ce que vous savez
pourquoi brûle parce que c'est
précisément pour ceux ci c'est pitié
en tout cas c'est vraiment moi j'ai que
ça à penser de 6gb coûte encore fait que
peu près 500 places parce que j'ai de
l'amsa bâton puis je comprends
exactement d'où mettons l'interprétation
puis de me tuerait d'avoir le même temps
prédation même genre d'interprétations
qu'olivier à 2-2 fatigués les stades ce
médecin si moi je me dis dire comment tu
comment tu peux voir ces images là puis
retenir que les statiques son faust et
c'est comme si tu es juste juste lu les
livres les fermes de saumons l'armée un
segment sur les fermes de saumons la
télé les mais c'est aussi ça fait partie
du fact checking que c'est que c'est
comme plus nuancée qu'est ce qui est dit
dans le documentaire mais moi le jeu
comme tout je m'en fous je suis comme
j'en ai vu des fermes de saumons ici au
québec puis c'est dégueulasse juste les
voir je les ai vus pis si ça passe en ce
mois là ce qui a fait partir demain
de ma réflexion c'est ça fait plusieurs
années puis même dame dans le journal
d'aurélie laflamme que j'étais en train
de relire en ce moment parce que tu es
je trouve que ça fait 15 ans puis
j'étais en train d'ajuster des petites
affaires qui ont mal vieilli hockey m
haies et aurélie à se questionner sur le
spécisme avant même que cherche que le
moose est saisie de 10 parce que c'est
moi ces maps et ma propre réflexion
c'est qui
c'est en ce moment j'ai des fourmis chez
nous il y en a une odeur qui me tombait
de la taille est l'objet des gros
questionnement là dessus pour lui -
olivier comme dit comme qu'est ce qu'on
fait on les dit on nous dit on et des
questionnements de même le cfa que fait
qu'un bref j'avais ces questionnements
le bain avant mais un enfant qui fait
partie de mon végétarisme ou véganisme
sais que mon âge est à l'est avec un
chef fréquente un chef ging j'étais allé
à la pêche avec lui moi j'ai jamais été
capable de pêcher quand j'étais petit
moi j'ai toujours été comme seuls outils
j'ai toujours été vegan dans l'homme
dans le fond parce que je n'ai pas
capable mon père sont chasseurs pêcheurs
puis moi j'étais pas capable ça me
faisait trop de haine qui pillulent le
chef péché qui sortaient les poissons
pis les îles et cogner sur la roche puis
parts à pleurer puis le voyons qu est-ce
que tout est rejetée comme mais je peux
pas croire que c'est comme ceux qu'on
continue un poisson on le sort de l'eau
pire et leye le oui mais c'est moins
c'est moins
cruel parce que dans le fond tu d'un
coup sûr sur la roche
plutôt que de l'ess laisser la section
et oui c'est se jeter comme mais les
deux ces critiques pour vous faites moi
ça fait partie de ce que je comprends
les gens de pauvres loire si on a des
habitudes alimentaires le pc tellement
anxiogène de dire mais j'adore les
sushis ses bons débuts le caje bolide
quand olivier pu m'en voulais devenir
vegan on se posait des questions de
santé mais qu'est ce qu'on va manger on
était tellement on avait le comme un
vertige de mais qu'est ce qu'on va
manger et honnêtement aujourd'hui
défonçant parle on se dit que c'est
qu'on aurait mangé pendant la pandémie
on avait trop recept qu'on faisait tout
le temps si on se demandait si non au
restaurant 6 tandis que le maintenant on
a comme une trentaine une liste longue
comme 50 recettes qu'on se fait puis les
sushis en marge du sushi momo et sushi
blum cas c'est tellement à vendre si je
donne tout quand je mange sushi mon
mouche comme mais j'aimais pas le sushi
j'avais les boules de riz bio avec des
maillots n'est qu'un sushi bobo existe
voyons on a tous besoin vraiment
d'ajouter du poids sont créés à ce seul
poisson je trouvais que ça dort chez le
goût parce que c'était que c'est comme
un petit 16 avait comme un petit goût de
bourgogne pas comment dire sur pied
alors qu'il ne planche pas si tu connais
le restaurant trop via le cap et prix
bas quasi frida iphone et touch and type
qui comme ce match était comme moi j'ai
pris l'autre fois j'étais allée chaque
fois que je passe par la carte puis
c'est quand même rare que je pense pas
car mais chaque fois je pense j'arrête
au café frieden nous avons un esprit d
chacun et noah forget
jardi poulet frites dégonfle c'est à mon
écoute c'est tellement dit on se fait
des recettes lopy ses piges comprend ccc
vraiment anxiogène pour les gens mes
qualités
les baleines sont en train de
disparaître dans mes recherches j'ai
découvert que les baleines bleues dans
les musées années 80 il y en avait 250
milles dans les océans
maintenant il reste cinq mille cfoot et
moi je ressens rouge de sang c'est
important je veux pas de mon vivant est
situé à l'âme a à la disparition les la
baleine noire ayant reste 350
quand j'ai commencé ma recherche il y en
avait quatre cents puis aujourd'hui on
est quatre ou cinq ans plus tard mais on
a 50 de moins puis continue d'avoir des
des échouages que les échouages sont
beaucoup causés par le trafic maritime
par les collisions pis par la surpêche
parce que yo deyo des baleines qui sont
en prison dans les filets page sur sa
rive non-stop le top je parlais à un
activiste justement pour mon livre
pylônes disait il me disait ça va être
un livre d'activistes mon livre de
baleine c'est un livre documentaire sur
les baleines mais c'est un livre
d'activités aussi parce que tu es fan de
ric o'barry pis je pense que moi même
c'est une activiste pitre comme sans
nécessairement aller avec des pancartes
ou à les filmer
moi je serais même pas capables d'en
voir une se faire tuer mais le monsieur
il me racontait que on n'a pas les
effectifs pour sauver les baleines puis
lui de se promène avec son bateau le
pili appelle des fois le sait comme une
baleine pris dans un filet site
on n'a pas les effectifs au québec pour
sauver toutes les baleines
il ya un groupe qui peut s'apprendre ça
prend des des autorisations et cherop
ils fournissent pas si c'est triste de
penser à six mois ça mais moi ça me fend
le coeur
ah oui un autre affaire fac tchéquie
olivier m
mpk pour devenir vegan on donne des
fausses informations sur la sambre donc
que le poisson votre rendre malade ne se
pose jamais parce
si ce levier des tests déjà pas d'entrée
du dr eagle qui fait apparition dans le
film jodie a dû lui c'est comme donner
des fausses informations pour faire peur
aux gens pour qu'ils arrêtent lui ai
jamais c'est que parce que lui donnait
des bonnes informations il était le tu
peux aller chercher son oméga 3 ailleurs
comme à ça c'est cool je t'avais le
poisson peut être un malade
ce lieu c'est lui qui décroche du fait
que ces puis je comprend six lots ou
est-ce que la fin justifie les moyens
puissent ce genre d'information nautique
ce qui est trompeur titre le poisson ça
peux pas te rendre malade mais tu est
obligé d'avoir du poisson pour avoir
déjà été obligées d'avoir du poisson
pour manger santé
ces lots ou qu' on peut se questionner
puis qu'on se dit mais l'oméga 3 tu peux
aller chercher dans plein d'autres
aliments et systèmes le sushi y existe
dans le monde c'est le supplément
attaque du supplément sur mes cheveux
exactement c'est comment on fait avec
l'abbé d'oscar devient vegan petit ce
donc c'est un autre là on est rendu
concevant une fondue au fromage et s'est
rendu tellement bon on a pris une
recette de jean-philippe puis au début
la première fois en paix comme art sa
sonde rixe safran plie pas notre besoin
finalement si on peut s'amuser avec les
recettes le on l'a on l'adapté on a
rajouté des choses qu'ils écoutent
maintenant le sait en fin de semaine ont
mangé ce ponte le module t on
des fois le pendant une fraction de
seconde j'oublie que j'entraîne manger
du fromage est notre affaire aussi parce
que le chinois et je trouve ça plate que
c'est les lits bataille de mots c'est
comme lille et la faire en ce moment le
comme le fromage l'appellation c'est de
la perte de ta parce que moi je trouve
ça cool parce que plusieurs laiteries en
ce moment là qu'ils sont en train de
développer des produits vegan mois là au
début quand je suis devenu vegan je me
disais il ya pas de hyogo qui me
satisfont pied riviera j'adore leur yoko
maintenant je suis rendu que je prends
juste geoghegan
alors qu'au début je me disais
végétarienne parce qu'il y avait un
certain
8 je t'ai pas capable de remplacer comme
le yogourt toutes les you go j'ai trouvé
dégueulasse
maintenant je prends le yogourt riviera
je laime dans ma mire ce que c'est ça
goûte presque paul comme tout qui je me
dis c'est laiterie le kiki il y en a une
autre entre autres le cas qui a commencé
à faire de la crds est menacée à
l'avoine et je trouve que c'est le fun
que des laiteries qui commence à faire
des produits vegan peut-être que sont
intelligents peut-être qui se dit c'est
l'avenir et peut-être éventuellement ils
vont faire une transition parce que
avoir des animaux ça coûte très cher
chaque image ici peuvent tuer comme
transitionner ouais mais le spa lève le
mot le style le mauvais temps les veaux
si la possibilité à ces laiteries le de
développer ce marché selon moi je
connais rien en économie il c'est mon
opinion le s'est basé sur rien c'est
juste un effort c'est juste à l'effort
de l'industrie pour mettre des bâtons
dans les roues au changement si ce n'est
qu'un seul les appellations comme ceux
ci les américaines marquées mais ça
c'est juste des poursuites de l'upr des
poursuites des producteurs de lait ou
des producteurs deux autres des oeuvres
du québec qui qui essaie de mettre des
bâtons néo alors que pourquoi on
permette on donnerait pas des
subventions à ses producteurs le que les
agriculteurs ne s'est pas une mauvaise
personne seule qui travaille à faire
pour là pour leur business et du monde
qui dans le monde vegan ça va prend des
agriculteurs à fond aussi exactement
puis je me dis pourquoi au contraire on
subventionne pas les innovations comme
justement de créer des yo gourd vegan
comme riviera a fait que c'est super bon
petit un produit québécois puisqu'il
s'est fait chez nous tout ce qui sait
tous les gens qui font du tofu moi
j'adore le tofu qui vient de 6,7 en
bosnie c'est ça c'est malade tes pieds
je me dis au contraire on devrait comme
encourager l'innovation pu permettre à
ses producteurs le d'utiliser ces mots
là pour aller chercher un marché puis le
olivier a découvert aussi que à olivier
se dévoiler
il y voit des affaires parce que tout y
est il s'intéresse beaucoup aux
véganisme toute simple mdi dit lola il
ya quelque chose qui vient de se passer
il observé mace rendu parce qu'avant la
recherche ces tests est souvent associé
à manger de la viande mais l'eau en asie
ça comme changer c'est comme la fosse
viande qui est rendu une preuve de
schiste
ça pourrait changer oui parce que j'ai
la grosse tendance de cambridge nord aux
dix minutes quantité de consommation
mais qu'un analysis a augmenté exact
mais le vu que la perception a changé
que c'est un symbole de richesse de
manger comme de la fosse viande que le
ça pourrait changer puis que ça pourrait
même développer des nouveaux produits
parce que c'est otis fait de la thur où
on va avoir de la bonne du bon stokes il
wes et ses petits des fois je te disais
à une fois temps en temps le je mange du
fromage en grains parce que ça manque
puis moi j'ai décidé comment j'ai décidé
d'être vegan ce que je veux pas être
dans le dans les dents m'empêcher de
manger des choses qui est fac au début
car je trouve quand je transitionner si
j'avais un creux ving je mange et puis
maintenant j'ai pu te réveilles de
viande j'ai même pu créer vignes de
fromage ya tellement d'affaires qui met
une fois de temps en temps sur une
poutine ça s'en vient il va hors de
cause bien tall qui va être l'équivalent
puis qui va être examiné tout c'est
comme le lait
le yogourt et au début je n'étais pas
capable puis finalement maintenant j'ai
besoin leurs trois pistes séparées
seulement que des goûts ont changé c'est
juste qu'il ya des banques sont
exactement
j'ai l'impression que ça s'en vient
guillaume olivier suisse le pied là et
le lion réussi à synthétiser la cazine
si je pense le club fromage chassant
revient bientôt avec lui et comme tout
le temps en train de voler nouvelles
comme ce fac est en mon dieu j'ai été
trop intense
les pro vélo d'équipements anti-émeutes
ont six enfants parallèle aussi avec ti
game schengen avaient tous participé
quatre ou six documentaires tv gagnent
le plus sur l'aspect santé ce maroc puis
en fait à chaque fois qu'un documentaire
qui sort tient-il les problèmes de
surpêche le problème c'est que qui
s'accroît que ça détruit la faune la
flore la faune la faune marine pitt seul
système monétique irréel une saine
pratique irréel puis au lieu de comme
regarder ces épisodes qu'il y ait
vraiment problématique on débouche sur
les détails finalement en même temps
timétrine changelog ce document talent
existe
ok pour dire aux gars s marcheteau fut
bâti torgau pareil puis moi la limite le
jeu trouve ceux qui obtenaient dans ce
sens que ok fac pour des gogos qui
peuvent être vegan faut qu'on manque des
gothiques qui lève dépôt faut que tu
dises au go est souvent dit bien
direction au sein d'un bébé là là le
public cible que c'était jean legault je
t'aime aller l'archétype du maure qui
montrent la viande sylvie quant à lui
qu'on voulait a réparé les petits
apprennent à faire dans ce documentaire
le ticket qui que justement au niveau
des faits nouveaux de la science qui est
et qui sont au trafic sont tronqués ou
que genre juste l'expérience en le
programmant une valeur scientifique mais
risque en bout de ligne et les athlètes
olympiques qui disent je vais gagnent je
me sens super bien pigeage mais je te
coupe non bah c'est mon problème
juste l'argument de dire il ya des
athlètes qui sera dévoile un pic qui
performent pareil
sachant tous les autres tous les
bienfaits qu'avec des gars sérieux sur
l'environnement bape sur l'éthique
animale
puis que tu peux être arrêté le niveau
de performance que ça change ça va pas
de nuire des performances c'est un
argument juste arrivé aux manettes
aceval habitait pas besoin de
d'amplifier d'autres statistiques ou de
tde pour que ton prince d'autres clubs
et on pointe assez fort comme l'aspect
aussi avec eux j'ai pas vu un métier que
je me dis l'arrêté la pratique était ma
réelle et forte de l'image que moody's
ont tellement forte que tu sais si c'est
juste dommage qu'on se steen sur les
éléments qui fonctionne petit truc
plutôt que le dire et qui est vraiment
problématique faut qu'on fasse de cours
je comprends ton point
pis si je veux me faire l'avocat du
diable peu parce que pas d'accord avec
toi mais parce que je veux représenter
le point de vue d'oeil vivent des gens
comme lui
si je vous donne un exemple game
challenge kg deux amis qui écoutent ce
ils font comme ils viennent souper chez
nous ça rend la pandémie et dix suspects
comme un oeuf en janvier passé c'est que
me dit au moment où qu'on avait encore
le droit du pdg et le apprenez nous à
être vegans nous on a écouté du game
changelog stella pourquoi vous voulez le
faire pour la santé a et lolotte c'est
comme si tu combien de temps ça dure et
leur véganisme 2 - 4 se donnent des
mauvais arguments aux gens le sait seul
danger mais en fait c'était un peu comme
au point que je l'aiderai sera fait qui
est quand même pas besoin de donner des
mavs et drogba au monde parce que les
bons arguments sont assez bons mais oui
mais il tient à la pointe de l'île saint
guen j'ai juste pu focus et sur
justement les témoignages des athlètes
olympiques surveillance a été en masse
comme si ce pays si je suis ce n'est
sûrement moins attendu l'espèce de mal
tu veux saisir explique wang
les clashs aussi se garder la balle
aurait moins parce que dans ses sorties
ça va être ça le tout exploser le tout
le monde ne parlait que de ceux ci c'est
juste un documentaire qui fait voici les
athlètes olympiques ne gagnent pas
d'inconvénient la même affaire legault
il peut déplacer des enfants il faut
dire j'ai dit bonne direction y'a pas de
sens et qui m'ont poussé bla bla bla tu
peux faire la même affaire qu'il y avait
des faits qui était bon l'autre comme
entre autres quand il explique justement
l'agriculture que l'agriculture est
présentement c'est ça sert à nourrir les
animaux qui servent à finalement nourrir
nous puisque toute la matière les
mathématiques de ce fonctionne faut
qu'un jour ça devrait être nourrir nous
qui ça prendrait moins d' espaces de
terrain qui se sait et c'est un bon feu
mais à travers des fêtes on c'est comme
si on dirait que quand les documentaires
comme ceux ils veulent proposer
l'alternative vegan comme solutions sont
andré qu'il faut qu'il nous fasse peur
avec la bouffe c'est ça c'est jamais une
bonne solution
parce qu'après ce les gens ils vont
devenir maintenant vegan pluies vont se
faire dit la bonne information for
disent oui ça peut pas me créer des
crises cardiaques puis des affaires
comme ça oh ben coudon ben je veux
recommencer à manger du steak sifac
c'est quand quelqu'un c'est pas dans son
cas mais quand on démonte les bonzes
argumenté les bons arguments
c'est quoi ce qu'elles apparaissent
chères problème c'est que les poissons
il ya un autre système nerveux ils
ressentent la douleur c'est des animaux
intelligents tcc ce qu'il faut essayer
de faire voir aux aux gens c'est
d'essayer de développer leur empathie
envers les animaux si je pense qu'on
vient d'une culture c'est moi juste mon
chien le jeu l'élève avec le
renforcement positif et quand je vois
des gens
et c'est comme être sec avec leur chien
outils faire des vieilles méthodes
d'entraînement ça me fait ça me fait de
la peine je peux pas m'imposer pour dire
ce que c'était un entraînement le triton
chantier mais je le vois qui on vient
d'une culture que moi quand j'ai eu un
chien au début je pensais que c'était
comme ceux qu'on ait levé un chien parce
que on vient tellement une culture où on
infériorisent les animaux qu'on pense
que c'est que c'est comme ce qu'il faut
à g mais je te jour là mon chien on
développe des méthodes de communication
on se comprend et puis je pense que
c'est comme ça aussi avec les toutes les
animaux puis avec les baleines moi ce
que j'ai appris c'est que les baleines
au site communiquent avec nous une
certaine façon quand les gens sont
habitués de travailler avec les baleines
ou avec les dauphins
il développe une communication avec eux
puis c'est la même affaire pour les
vaches t-il evatt moelleux s'est rendu
le témoin j'adorais l'amour est dans le
pré le g2 l'hamza regarder ce jeune
camarade je le vois que les agriculteurs
1e leurs animaux
mais j'ai de la misère à regarder les
vaches dans un petit essai ross et puis
qu'est-ce qu'on regardait aussi à huy
ont regardé le documentaire sur kyushu
cru se sépare donc je pense que la
victime mais et puis le les créateurs le
2 2 kg où le lion band perry d'écossé
pour découvrir ce qui a fait qu'ils nous
montrent autres mais bref et une
porcherie
tu vois les cochons la note ccc sol et
des clash on est dans la culture pop en
personne
le documentaire c'est pour découvrir
c'est qui qui en arrière de qt a retracé
l'histoire de qui ou du mouvement qui me
donne pour ceux qui quoi quand une
escapade addictives comme un
documentaire
moi j'ai un deuil c'est une série où sa
série documentaire sur creil c'est super
bowl qui est en tout cas métier tout
tout c'est ici
si ces images le deport shérif de cochon
qui n'ont pas de place dans leur petit
enclos ans que ruby moi c'est comme je
me dis 4 4 si seule une forte c'est
quelque chose
mathis fait pour retourner en arrière si
c'est comme moi ma bague de mariage le
hockey moi j'ai appris que que les
diamants site est basé beaucoup sur
l'esclavagé ce qu'on appelle le blood
diamond et vainqueur je suis venu pour
me marier j'ai pas envie de m'acheter un
diamètre si c'est une compagnie créée
par leonardo dicaprio fait qu'un film
après qui a fait blood diamond et green
compagnie qui recrée de façon
synthétique et tout l'environnement pour
faire des diamants donc c'est des
diamants qui sont créées synthétiquement
mais ça donne des vrais diamants quand
même mais c'est juste que c'est des
diamants créé en laboratoire au lieu
d'être créée dans la nature qui est de 2
de leurs exploiteurs et exploités des
humains mais moi le cas j'apprends
quelque chose le à prisches une fois que
tu sais tu n'es pas le dessin noir avec
moi c'est comme ma vision de la vie je
trouve je me dissocie et ben ouais pas
mal de continuer une action à sa chance
et coquet derrière faut que ceux-ci
l'action complètement c'est ça moi c'est
comme au quai à partir du moment que
chez quelque chose qu'est ce que je peux
faire
puis moi j'ai acheté cette bague le
hameau côté 250 quinze jours je me dis
comme j'en reviens pas que fait que
j'aurais payé comme 10000 pièces et le
second pour une bague comme pour moi
c'est comme si je respecte les gens qui
le font mais du moment où moi je sais
que kitty faut tout à respecter les
choix des autres et si tu es capable de
t'expliquer que tu es capable d'acheter
quelque chose qui vienne industrie qui
exploite des humains ou des animaux le
dise au son de la respecter quand même
des choses que je compte y mettant des
choses que qu'on comprenne je comprends
pas ce que c'est parce que c'est la
norme le président à respecter
je crois qu est ce que tu veux dire
m'ont dit que des choses qui bien il ya
des fautes on le sait poser comme l'ont
récemment j'ai lu des affaires sur le
coton le ch comme picasso si c'est de
l'esclavagé incluses comme ok mais
comment je fais pour savoir mon cochon
vient d'où
des fois c'est comme la vega ne sais que
tu sais pas par où commencer pour savoir
ces choses le but
il consomme et 100% éthique surtout
c'est pratiquement impossible c'est un
vertige mais c'est moi je pense que faut
essayer de le faire c'est le cg moi
j'essaye de le faire le plus possible
quand quelqu'un dit quelque chose c'est
comme le jeu porte des jeans site et je
sais que c'est super bon pour
l'environnement
tout ce qui quand je l' ai appris bon
j'ai arrêté de marcher dit jean dit oui
mais c est ce que est ce que je vais
être capable si j'aime dit jane
d'arrêter de me racheter iti c'est un
moment donné là c'est ça devient lourd
sur les épaules du consommateur pour moi
c'est pour ce que je trouve qu'il faut
pas blâmer les consommateurs des fois
des documentaires comme ceux il ya un
peu le souci c'est que ça prend des
déréglementations puis des politiques
classe compte ce qui je ne sais pas
qu'est ce que ça va prendre pour
convaincre sarabande que ce que soit
rendue emprise de bain à prendre les
pays de l'est décision a eu ce
raisonnement ne puis j'ai lu quelque
chose à un moment donné le saut
l'industrie du tabac qui au québec mais
il y avait des avait des terres de table
ok puis le cas on a vu que le tabac
était probant pour la santé c'est
peut-être le haut que des fois les gens
sont tentés par la santé c'est de
l'argument santé mais il ya eu des
subventions pour que les agriculteurs
changent leur la loge un large champ qui
au début ça fait une grogne ici et j'en
voulais pas changer hypno nana qui
finalement aujourd'hui
et moi je m'achète du vin québécois que
je trouve super bon et il ya eu des
chants qui ont été changés à b en
vignoble il y en a qui ont été changés
pour des champs de pommes ou des choses
comme ce petit on boit du cidre on
achète des premiers coise des choses
comme ça le jeu steam je me dis c'est
possible finalement de mettre de
l'argent pour changer quelque chose qui
moi c'est sûr que ce serait mon rêve pis
c'est sûr que j'aimerais ça de mon
vivant
seul véhicule changement j'aimerais ça
qui qui qui qui de voir la population de
baleines bleues recommencer un croissant
une place où je vais le aux bergeronnes
que le monsieur sait j'adore seul le
monsieur qui possède le terrain on jase
tout le temps puis me disait petit il
dit à 20 ans le je regarde l horizon le
petit a sur ce terrain là tu peux voir
les baleines t'es pas obligé d'aller
dans un bateau le les baleines et
viennent d'éditer sur une roche le pied
une baleine c'est curieusement chaque
côté de toi le puits une dizaine loti tu
regarde l horizon le pit avait dix
autres avaient dit que tu avais comme 50
baleines devant toi là de toutes sortes
de toutes sortes de baleine c'est
maintenant il ya des petit rorqual puis
se voit des ide au un temps en temps
puis le cas que les gens sur ce terrain
là il voit la baleine c'est où
mais avant ce déguisement banales
tellement il y en avait dans l'horizon
si le y en a presque pu ces styles et
les baleines le sait un bio indicateur
sujet après cependant mon documentaire
de que je fais sur les baleines un
bio-indicateur c'est la partie visible
ok mais si les baleines disparaissent le
pseudo que tout le reste en dessous et
déjà puis c'est un palace est ce pire si
la partie visible c'est qu'est-ce qui le
lot en étant le long on est en train de
se faire dit il ça fonctionne plus il ya
des échouages il y au moins une baleine
tout il ya quelque chose qui ne marche
pas votre chéquier sur toutes les autres
couches qui se veut voir que on sait on
est dans merde fait que prenons dont
action toute la chine est le moteur qui
font qu'il est ici paul carroll qui
étudie le la bande à david le lay
phytoplancton le ticket qui dit la
biologie marine stallman atypique et il
le plancton lundi qu'il est plus laborde
jeunes est le moteur marine et est en
voie de disparition le factice sap est
apprécié et c'est toute la chaîne
l'équipe prend le barça c'est comme
c'est pas juste les baleines c'est comme
si le seyon complet les kits en danger
en ce moment la mitis des espèces qui
l'eau les espèces qui disparaissent on
envoie de notre vive armes et il y en a
eu avant ils vont en avoir après je vois
ça fait dix mille lacs et des espèces
qui disparaissent à cause de l'homme
depuis quand à g
en amérique il y avait des mammifères
géants et styles y avait des toutes
sortes d'animaux incroyable qu'on est
juste chassé après ceux ci lisa cm a
précisé
c'est quand même année quand est-ce que
ça arrête là puisque à venir se
retrouver tout seul estime cédric ont
détruit tout sur tout
c'est quand je vois la pandémie moi j'ai
peur que ça changerait puis j'ai peur
que les gens aient pas et et envie de
tout retrouver ce qu'ils avaient avant
de le mans c'est j'ai peur que ça change
rien on sait il faut que ça change aussi
ça apporte le bien 10 et il faut
s'attendre à au faux pas que ça change
juste d'un point de vue individuel on a
une responsabilité individuellement pour
essayer de faire changer la demande sauf
qu'il faut que ça change a aussi revu sa
change le plus rapidement possible
je pense oui immédiat merci infiniment
non mais tant mieux tant mieux je
voulais qu'on en parle qu'on n'avait pas
parlé de gagny merci infiniment
on invite les gens se procurer son livre
on invite les gens te suivent à suivre
tout ce que tu fais tu peux toutes les
plateformes du plugin et on a parlé le
point sur les baleines sauce ekwa ses
deux sorties ou sinon ça va sortir cet
automne
ça va être super bon c'est un livre
illustré pied côté psy c'est vraiment un
mélange entre documentaire pied
aussi mes valeurs ça fait que je me suis
fait refuser dans quelques maisons
d'édition alors oui je pense que les
gens voulaient que j'écrive un livre qui
était plus documentaire documentaire
puis que je laisse le côté et métis j'ai
trouvé trois fois j'ai trouvé un éditeur
qui était comme qui a décidé d'aller
dans le sens que je voulais à l'époque
j'étais vraiment contente de ce parce
que moi je fais des livres sur les
baleines qui dit que ce les baleines ça
mange plus tout seul tu peux d'en
trouver
mais moi c'est comme qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire pour les baleines facchetti
ce tout un mélange entre justement mon
côté activistes puis mon côté je veux je
veux informer les gens qui marchent et
qui s'est bien sorti merci beaucoup en
très vite rational
merci d'avoir écouté ce podcast jusqu'à
la fin de ce père que vous avez apprécié
la conversation ça prouve que vous êtes
de réelles fans de conversation et du
sans-fil pas de cas si l'on vous
remercie vraiment beaucoup
si vous voulez avoir plus de contenus
plus de conversation c'est sûr
pétillante que ça se passe hier sur
petra non seulement on met tous les
podcasts en ligne au moment où est ce qu
on les tourne donc on a beaucoup de
semaine d'avant sur le pétrole mais on
fait aussi des encore moins de filtres
qui sont exclusifs au monde pétulant
nous aussi on parle d'homme nicole et
moi de la conversation qu'ont bien
d'avoir ce qu'on met un peu plus en
profondeur dans certains sujets qu'on
voulait aborder ou qu'on a abordé
pendant le podcast donc allez sur notre
page rituels et le lien vers savoir dans
la description du podcast fait qu'il ya
merci encore une fois nous avons écouté
jusqu'à la fin